I despise this guy from the second I heard him speak, okay? So,
I'm not going to let it go. >> The whole point of being
a content creator should be that you are more intelligent than
the total cattle that watch you. Do not bring that super Toastify
thing up. Please don't. >> What? No. What? >> He's
a total HE'S A TOTAL PAYPIG. WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> He wanted you to think that he was innocent, naive,
a boy failure, someone who's inexperienced in relationships and
would never hurt a fly. Because in reality, behind this mirage,
this illusion, there was a master manipulator, a serial cheater,
and a predator. Someone who would make it a point for many years
to target smaller content creators, take full advantage of the
fact that he was one of the most desirable men in the streaming
world, all while making it seem like he had no experience with
women and that it just might be romantic. They just might be
that special someone who can fix him. What he would somehow forget
to tell them, though, is that he had been in a monogamous relationship
since 2021.
But, you don't have to take my word for it because he admits
to everything in a recorded voice call with the victim herself.
And on top of that, that same victim, who goes by the name of
Hemam Malvi T, would choose to write a Google Doc that shows
the entire timeline, her and Sykkuno's DMs together, as well
as the DMs of another victim that actually slept with Sykkuno
while being totally oblivious to the fact that he has been in
a relationship since 2021.
Here's the thing, okay? I I guess this is probably what I think
the split is. Is I think it's all based on gender. Yeah, you
could predict it entirely based on your gender. If you're a guy,
you think this is nothing.
It turns out that women feel particularly put off when they find
out a guy has been lying to them to get in their pants. And I
don't think guys ever experience that. And so, there's like absolutely
no empathy here, and most of you, including like the people here
in this chat, you literally don't have the
IQ required to
project and and and consider empathetically what another person
would think and imagine experience you've never had. And so you
guys are like, well that's not a thing. Like it's just yeah,
yeah guys are dogs and they lie to you to to [__]
you. What that's the way the world works. Like
the women are reacting a certain way right? This is a big deal
to them and I I understand that. It makes sense to me. I don't
like being lied to. I don't know everybody else here is like
The the craziest thing to me about the Mujin thing, not the Mujin
thing, the Sykkuno thing, is so many people have had this insane
brain damage take that this didn't need to be public.
And I'm like, okay. If Sykkuno was talking to these women and
let's say hypothetically Sykkuno
conning these women out of like 50
Each each person, he's conning each person out of 50 bucks. Does
that not need to be public? Hey, this guy is like a big name.
People respect him. They start conversations with him. They don't
have their guard up and then he cons them out of $50. When is
it okay to tell people about that
And then explain to me why you care more about $50 than somebody
being like emotionally toyed with to get in their
Go ahead. Explain to me why you're a total psychopath.
Cuz not a single person on this entire planet would be upset
if it was about $50 getting conned out, right?
>> You think that Mujin has been upfront about his involvement
in this drama. Is that correct? >> Yeah, I well, for two
reasons. One, within like I think 30 minutes of the doc dropping,
he had a full edited video out the door. So he had to be complicit
with them the whole time.
And then he drops the YouTube comment saying he's complicit with
them. That he's been working on this with them. Thank that he
thanks them for trusting him with this. >> Yeah, but that's
what I'm saying, okay? So, I think you've actually portrayed
his alleged involvement in the story so far. He's saying that
he's receiving information from them and that they have given
him this information and he's going to be the first one to be
able to make a Google like a YouTube video about it.
>> Do you think that that's been his only
He's just received this information and he's been given the first
mover advantage.
>> No, I would assume that he's like if they had something
that was like super [__] in there that he said, "Hey,
you shouldn't include this." Or something along those He could
have. So, there's obviously a whole bunch of I went on a whole
rant about this why you shouldn't help people with stuff like
this. So, that's why I'm confused is cuz for some reason I went
on a whole rant yesterday while I was covering this about how
you shouldn't help people put together like a doc like this as
the YouTuber as a drama YouTuber cuz there's too many there's
too many conflicts, right? You can't You can't separate yourself
out from the conflicts. So, obviously, you shouldn't help cuz
no matter what happens, people are going to blame you. Like if
anything goes wrong unless it's 100% without a hitch, everybody
will blame you for how that went.
I was I went on a whole rant about this. So, I'm not sure I actually
was just looking at my VOD trying to see what the [__]
was I What What did I see that made me go in the opposite direction
of you and say, "Hey, you really shouldn't have been this close
to this. You're too close to this in general."
>> Um well, I think I mean, I agree with this stuff. I
don't think that he should have got quite so involved.
However, okay? I don't think that Mujin has made a decision to
like get involved. I think he's like squarely on the team. He's
not like an advisor. He's like one of the guys pushing this to
come out. So, the document, okay? The way that that is written,
these people had help with writing it, right? You can Can we
agree with that?
>> Why do we think he they got help from him and not like
Chat GPT or something? >> They could do, but the way that
this stuff is phrased doesn't seem like Chat GPT. So, the opening
line being "On Valentine's Day this year, I was followed on Twitter
by Sykkuno." "I thought that it was amazing such a big content
creator even knew I existed, let alone followed me on social
media. He had been my role model and somebody I looked into for
a long time, ever since my days in high school. However, what
I learned about Sykkuno after that day made me regret my decision."
That's not somebody who's like going with a title about my allegations
against Sykkuno or my exposé against
And then just like dryly going through it, maybe giving commentary.
That's somebody who's like going there for like a hook. I think
that's somebody who knows how to make drama content. >> This
is a 19-year-old girl. >> Do we Yeah, yeah, yeah. I Is
this not like a cultural phenomenon at this point that people
do Google documents with these allegations? I >> And yet
somehow like everything that a 19-year-old puts together
is like a thousand pages long. >> Sure, this is 30 pages
long and it really should have It could have This could have
been four pages long. That's another reason Like, I'm not sure
maybe he really wanted to get like a whole other narrative in
here. I feel like if he's a drama YouTuber Like, as somebody
who streams drama stuff, when I read this, I see all the extraneous
Like, all the stuff about her getting bought for her, right?
That's all extraneous to me. I don't think that actually builds
their narrative whatsoever. If he were involved, I would expect
him to cut the stuff that's just not relevant, not super important.
>> So, Mutjin has a
a Google document with guide with a advice that he gives people
on how to write Google Docs. Now, he says that a maximum that
it should be is 50 pages and anything lower than that is like
what you should go with. But, I think that the claims are kind
of it's overly long because I I watched your coverage but I I'm
so possibly disagree but I think that the actual allegations
haven't got that much meat on the bone. This is a guy who's like
been sleeping around on Discord. But he's already got a girlfriend.
But there's not that much meat on the bone. >> are the
allegations?
Um he is a serial cheater, liar, and manipulator. He uses status
to get what he wants from as many women as possible. More specifically,
ones who are smaller or up-and-coming content creators, knowing
that he could take advantage of I think that's conclusively proven
by this document. >> Taking advantage is maybe got like
some moral load in there which I might disagree with but in terms
of his >> of smaller VTubers?
>> Does he really want like battle partners? He just wants
content >> Um well I I don't have an answer for you but
that's like a leading question. >> Well I I mean I have
an answer for me cuz I know that basically I went through and
and looked at a bunch of them who were coming out and they're
all like hot, right? They're all like in-person people who do
VTubing
and they're all hot.
>> I'm I'm saying like he he's he's looking for like >> partners,
right? And they're tagged line, right? They've like they're putting
out >> Yeah, they're all He's looking for partners which
like I have no problem with that. The problem with that is the
way he presents himself, right? As someone who's like super innocent,
doesn't isn't really doing this.
>> Yeah, he's like he's like going around and being a and
like sleeping with people and cheating on his girlfriend when
he like actually is a person who's closer than >> have
no problem with him even trying to have to these women. My problem
is basically him lying to them, presenting them like with a an
idea of like a relationship, misrepresenting what you want out
of that interaction. If he was just honest and up front and like,
"Hey, I'm just I'm looking for somebody who I'm like Let's say
you're in an open dynamic with his girlfriend. If he was just
open about what was going on, saying, "Hey, I'm not looking for
something long-term." I think these women still would have [__]
them and he
like anybody who did would have still. Obviously not the first
girl cuz she literally didn't.
But I I just don't see any reason for him to do this kind of
lying. And I do think it it sets women up to be like like hurt.
Like it's just it's doing harm in the world for no reason.
>> Yeah, yeah. What I'm saying is like, okay. So, this
document presents like an eight because of the extra allegations
in there or the extra angles that they tried to go to, when actually
it's like a two. It's like a cheating drama,
>> Uh I don't So, these are the things that they lay out
that he's a serial cheater. >> pattern of love bombing
and >> Okay. Cal- I mean, he obviously love bombs and manipulates.
Is it calculated? I don't know. You You like don't like the adjectives,
I guess.
>> Well, no, but I'm saying that a lot of that behavior
is integral to the cheating, right? So, if you say like manipulation,
him saying, "No, I'm single." If that's manipulation, that's
fine, but that's cheating, right? >> I mean,
I think this has to do with So, manipulation is also the idea
that he's like not talking to other women repeatedly, right?
So, not just the cheating, but also that he is like, "Oh, I've
never talked to women before. I don't do anything like this."
That's
>> When he's like literally got a roster? >> Um well,
there's allegations that he's got a roster, but I don't think
there's anything proven in here that he's got like a huge list
of girls. >> have you looked at Twitter and all of the
people he was hitting up and all of the people he had like interactions
like this with? >> Um I think I've seen a couple people.
One of them has This was a while ago, apparently, and then they
like private to their account. And then somebody else went and
like deleted that tweet. Um >> But By the way, >> any
given time that he's Yeah, go on. >> Sorry, I don't want
to I don't want to like totally make it I don't want to totally
gaslight you and make it sound like I've no idea what you're
talking about. But I I just explain away how hyperbolic they
are, like with the dangerous predator thing in the tweet, with
like they're V-tubers and anything that's like a three for us
is like an 11 for them. And that that's like I go into it with
that understanding. And like when I read it, like to me the point
of doing analysis on a document like this is to see what the
facts actually bear out and not really to go oh, you guys are
like being a little hyperbolic in this direction or that direction.
It's like to figure out who the good people are, what the bad
actions are, who to call out based on what the evidence is
And like I don't necessarily think the Hemel all person is a
good person either, but like Saikou knows definitely a total
loser. Like he is a pathological liar it seems like like he had
this set up. He was lying to multiple women in the exact same
way. Now it's not all proven out in the doc, but when you go
and talk to some of the other people, you see some of the other
people, he was cheating with multiple other women. >> Yeah,
but there are DMs showing that he was trying to multiple women
too.
What I'm saying here is that like okay,
going back to it, right? The reason why there's several different
chapters here that seem extraneous is because these are claims
that they care about that you and I don't care about, right?
So there's not that much meat on the bone. And yet these girls
that he's with cheats on his girlfriend with are being painted
as victims because he's saying that he doesn't have a girlfriend
and then he's sending them money. >> No, they're victims
because they basically had their expectations like with to further
this relationship. >> Or the very least they were lied
to >> manipulated about him being single and about him
wanting a long-term relationship where they live together, got
a pet together, all of this. And then that's that's a lie. That's
a manipulation to get in their pants.
You don't think that the DMs where he's talking to the girl is
like a sincere effort to actually say we should move in together,
right? On the second day that they were like speaking or or flirting.
>> Um I think I think he was doing stuff like this like
literally and and continued to talk about how this would all
work. Like you could say it's not sincere at all, right?
But it seems like he's doing this quite a bit and it seemed like
she took it >> Um so if if somebody is taking it seriously
in this situation >> Sure, but she's like she's not taking
that seriously. >> So, she's taking it seriously in that
situation. A reasonable person goes, "No, no, no, no, no. I'm
just I'm playing around where obviously I realize it's just new,
this is how I talk." Clarification, right?
>> Like obviously we've all had this happen where you you
say something like that, right? Hey, let's just run away and
get married together. And the person goes like, "Oh, yeah, let's
you know, I have They start entertaining it seriously." And you're
like, "I'm joking."
Did he do that? >> No, but it seems like she's turned it
down and so it's like, "Okay, this is never going to happen,
right?" She's like got university, the commitments are not going
to be there, so it's like, "Okay, right."
Sure. The thing that I'm interested in that in that DM exchange
though, is that there is like 5 minutes missing
from that.
>> Yeah, I I did say that while I was covering it. >> I
I did say that while I was covering it that I did see places
where there were holes. Like not even I didn't see a a temporal
hole in like the DMs, but I I saw that like essentially if he
said he was joking there, uh one thing I was thinking about was
if it came out that his girlfriend was like okay with this, like
him [__] other people. She's obviously not now. Now
that I got to the end of the video. But early on I was like,
"If that ever came out, you all look totally [__]
insane for this, right?"
>> Yeah. But you Okay, so rolling back, are you aware that
some of these screenshots
I would say in like an outwardly deceptive way. >> Please
do not do not bring that super [__] toastify thing
up. Please don't. >> What?
What? Okay, come on. Why do you think it's [__]
>> Um because there's literally no information in that
that's not already included. Uh Connor wouldn't play this out
yesterday. That's a >> yes, it is. Yes, there is. Hold
on. So, the information that's not included after the crop happens
is, "I just wanted to know if it was true or if I was
So, this person is receiving this third-hand information. >> Yeah,
did you look at Connor respond
>> Did you look at Connor respond to this
on Twitter.
No, hold on.
Is there some part of that that's not relevant that was already
mentioned in the doc and screenshotted that I'm missing? It seems
just repetitive of the already presented info unless there's
something else I'm not
I'm going to go through this thread later. Um Do you not think
that it's important to be able to like show that that person
isn't even sure of it
Cuz that's been presented as proof of the allegation, no? >> Yeah,
so basically when she first come Well, hold on. It's It's being
used as proof of the allegation.
>> Or evidence rather.
>> Sure, but the way it's presented, if you just look at
this, it already says, "Hey, this is a rumor. I heard there was
possibly an instance." She's already saying she doesn't know
if it's true. Like there's no information that's included afterwards
that is required to say what's already been said. It is quite
literally extraneous. >> Wait, wait, wait, so they called
and Bow explained to her that other women had confided in her
about experiences with him. That makes it sound as though Bow
was receiving this firsthand. No? >> Uh say that again.
>> Okay, so they called and Bow explained to her that other
women had confided in her about similar experiences with him.
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure. >> firsthand information
that Bow had, >> So she described the pattern of behavior
where he told these women from other content creators and pressured
them into having sex. Bow then offered to to connect her with
these victims to share their experience with her directly as
if he thought felt it was important to hear them firsthand. >> It
was discussed in a Discord call. Yeah, yeah, sure, sure, sure.
Yep. >> And then you've got somebody here and this is like
evidence to go with the statement above. "Hi Bow, sorry to bother
you with this, but I heard something recently that was a bit
concerning and I thought I would come and ask you about it. I
heard there was possibly an instance of Sykkuno but uh
>> And then the rest of the crop shows that this person
is like doubting the
>> I don't think that it's like So there's no new information,
but the color of the request or the color of the information
presented is not sincere. >> Um I don't I still disagree
entirely. So, what they did here, it seems like, is they probably
put the screenshot
too low. It should probably be like the paragraph about they
called Bow to explain. That should This screenshot should be
right after she asked Bow if it it was true that the tweet was
about Saikou no. That's what the That's what the tweet is. That's
what I'm saying That's what the message is. Is this true about
Saikou no? Was this actually about Saikou no? And then the next
part is they called So, it's not explaining that they called
part. It's actually meant to It's just a paragraph off. I think
if you move the tweet then it Sorry, if you move the Discord
message, it's like all the way on, I
Okay. Let me see if you agree with this. So, the first The first
paragraph is the allegation, okay? And then every other part
of the screenshot is reasons why the person might not be confident
about the information they've heard. So, I understand a lot of
he said, she said rumors go around, but it was something that
was concerning to me. So, I wanted to ask you. Thank you so much.
I also wasn't told when or how long ago, but it was something
they heard. So, this person is hearing not directly from the
source, but this even to them is second or third-hand information.
>> And they don't want anything to come of
You can see again at the their lack of certainty in this. It's
literally like a pure rumor that they heard. >> Yes. So,
who We we know this is Saikou no's girlfriend, right? Who's sending
this message? >> Um bum bum bum bum bum bum. Um yes.
>> Yeah, sorry. I'm saying I'm saying that I I should just
say it as a statement. It's Saikou no It's Saikou no's girlfriend
who's sending the message.
Uh so, basically the this is used to show that she sent the message
to the Bow person. It goes with the statement above. And then
they called Bow They don't have like a proof of this in the
but all of this stuff like, I'm assuming when they put this out,
you don't do this with massive creators and say they told me,
I talked to them, they told me about all of these things.
And then, like, it's not technically sourced, right?
But, again, the girlfriend isn't sure of this, and she's saying
the the content the Sorry, the doc creator is saying, "I've talked
to the girlfriend. I've talked to this Bow person. We figured
things out." The She's writing this like after all of this has
happened, right? This isn't meant to prove that that anything
except that the girlfriend had talked to this Bow person. And
I have no idea how this girl would have gotten it unless she
talked to Bow or the girlfriend. Those are the only two people
who could have given her the screenshot. So, like, she's writing
all of this while being in contact with these people, provably.
And
>> I just don't see any reason why None of this None of
this seems I don't even know what we think is possibly not true
What do we think is What do we think she's like hesitant of?
Like, at this point, we know that this is true. >> But,
the Okay, but then she talked to the Bow person. Do you want
the proof of the call with the Bow person to confirm that the
rumor is true?
>> No, no, no, no, no. Okay.
The only The only reason why I'm saying this, okay, is if you
cut off the rest of the message, do you agree, okay, not in direct
information kind of like pieces that you can pull out of it,
but the framing is incredibly different.
>> If For example, if I send a If I send like a Discord
message to you, and I say, "Hey, I heard that Queenman was sleeping
with uh No. Aiden, okay? I heard that Queenman was sleeping with
Aiden. Somebody told me that Queenman was sleeping with Aiden."
And then the rest of my message is giving like uncertainty. "I
heard this. I'm not sure when. >> There's already There's
already uncertainty here. >> No any of these details.
Yeah, yeah, but the Okay. >> It is literally extraneous.
There's already uncertainty here. I heard that there was a poss-
possibly an instance of Psyquno trying to do this.
But if I'm reaching out to her asking
I Yeah, I Sorry, I I think it is and is there any difference
in how you read those two things? >> it's extraneous because
literally like this is proven out and she's already talked to
this person and that's like known that it's about Saikouno. The
tweet was about Saikouno. Like the tweet she did, this story
or whatever. Well, hold on. >> that follow button. I got
a donut here.
>> Yeah, no problem. So, this tweet Sorry, it really doesn't
matter because she is like saying
that this did happen. So, like regardless of what happened in
terms of her being uncertain when she reached out, why is the
level of uncertainty when she reached out? Let's say Let's say
you were correct. For one thing, even if that were true, given
that it's now confirmed, why does the level of certainty of the
girlfriend matter? Like slightly minimizing the level of certainty
of the girlfriend when she reached out to Bow?
Why would that even matter to the doc at
I don't understand. >> Uh because it hinges about whether
or not it's actually true.
>> No, then she says she called Bow. >> of the girlfriend
is the uncertainty of whether whether or not this happened. Especially
after this follows on from being told, "Don't go on that date
for your own personal safety." I think the implication is pretty
clear here.
>> Sorry. So, yes, but they are saying that happened without
a source. They are They are literally saying that happened using
Bow and her like proclivity to respond to stuff like this. Like
they are They're saying they talked to her. So, I That's why
I asked you, did you want proof of the call with Bow that they
are in contact with Bow? I don't understand how they get this
DM if they're not in contact with Bow.
>> Yeah, it it seems like they are in contact with Bow.
That's not what I'm disputing here. Or that's not even my
>> So, you Are you concerned about the possibility that
despite being in contact with Bao and using her invoking her
directly, the contact with her invoking her directly to say that
this was about the the tweet was about Saikou
Are we What are we missing here? >> We're we're we're not
missing anything. I'm not I'm not even saying, "Oh, this is probably
untrue. We need more evidence here." The only thing that I'm
saying is that this screenshot has been cropped to include the
allegation about what potentially happened and not include the
rest of the reasons why the person is not sure about it. I think
that quality >> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Those statements are absolutely
>> But so basically
I'm I'm coming to you. I'm writing a document, okay? I'm writing
a document and this this image is like basically showing that
two people talked and I've talked to them. That's what it proves
for me, right? The image talks about the level of certainty of
the girlfriend.
>> So it proves that she asked Bao if the tweet was too
about Saikou no. If it If it was true that the tweet was about
Saikou no, that's what it's
He asked Bao if it was a true if it was true that the tweet was
about Saikou no. That's what it's proving. >> Wait, wait,
wait. Okay.
You don't think that this has got anything at all to do with
earlier being warned about your own personal safety? This allegation
that maybe something happened when somebody was invited up to
a hotel >> that's what I'm saying is >> are connected
at all? >> No, they they they are connected >> and
the uncertainty is very important to that picture.
>> They are connected.
But the problem is the uncertainty is resolved but without proof.
They are saying explicitly, "No, that tweet was about him. I
talked to her. That tweet was about him." That's not what this
proves. They put it in the wrong place. It should be a like a
paragraph above.
So this proves
>> This proves only that they're all in
Right? This this isn't being used to prove anything. It's being
used to prove that she has Bow if the tweet if the it was true
that the tweet was about >> No, no, no. I don't think the
tweet is in the wrong place at all, Jay Stalk. I >> No,
I'm saying the tweet is in the right place. I keep meaning the
the Discord messages in the right place. >> the screenshot,
the screenshot of the Discord, yeah. I think it's exactly where
they wanted it to be cuz they're talking about having a conversation
with Bow and how women came to Bow directly to express similar
experiences with them, including being pressured into And then
right underneath in the document, you've got this where somebody
is saying, "Hi, sorry to bother you with this, but apparently
this guy has been inviting girls up to his hotel room. Seems
like there's an allegation there." >> This is the This
is the girlfriend, Sakuna's girlfriend who's messaging Bow. >> It
would It would seem to be that, yeah. >> Yeah, which is
what she is saying happened above, that Jay and it's like probably
pasted in here late. But either way, she is asserting that this
is true. And so the level of certainty of the girlfriend actually
makes no difference to the talk because they're making a way
stronger claim that if it fell apart would totally make them
look insane. But like this the reason I don't think it's being
used to prove that he was that like any of the claim in the in
the paragraph just above is because it's literally just the girlfriend
asking, "I heard there was possibly an instance of Sakuna doing
this and I heard recently uh something recently that was a bit
concerning. I thought I would just come to you and ask you about
it. I heard that there was possibly this thing going on." She's
already uncertain.
>> Okay. But is this it And you're saying that this Discord
screenshot here is being put in the wrong place and it's got
nothing to do with the pattern where he's targeting small female
content creators and pressuring them into having Do you see there's
no implication in your mind that this screenshot is being used
to evidence that? The only thing that it's purpose for is to
say that, "Oh, the girlfriend spoke to Bow."
>> So, is it evidence for that? >> Is it evidence
for what, sorry? Is it evidence of this? It's it
I don't know. Maybe I should draw this out cuz I feel like we're
missing and I don't know where we're missing. So, I'm I'm saying
it is evidence that they're all in contact and she's saying based
on this contact, Bow told this
told to explain to her, Sykkuno's girlfriend, that other women
had confided in her about similar experiences with Sykkuno.
He described a pattern of behavior where he targeted small female
content creators and pressured them into having sex with them.
Bow then offered to connect her with these other victims so that
they could share their experiences with her directly as she felt
it was important to hear them firsthand.
This was discussed during a Discord call. So, they don't have
the Discord call here.
Right? But they're saying, "Look, this is how you know that I'm
telling the truth because I have the screenshot of Sykkuno's
girlfriend talking to Bow."
what what's what what's cut here is the context of well, she's
not certain about it. Well, I don't think that's really cut context.
And it's This is literally not proof of the conversation that
happened or anything. They're just asking you to trust them that
they talked to Bow and Bow's explaining this to them or the girlfriend's
explaining them. Somebody around Bow is explaining it to them.
Maybe Bow is working with I have no idea. Like like it's I just
the level of certainty is irrelevant because they're literally
saying the other stuff happened. The level of certainty of the
girlfriend is irrelevant because they're just saying it happened.
These these Discord calls happened. >> Okay. Right. And
you're saying that they didn't show the entire message because
they were short on space.
>> No, I I don't know why they didn't show the rest. It's
it is extraneous.
>> If you had to if you had to guess if you had to guess
why they didn't show the rest cuz they've already got evidence
that the guys have spoken together on the very next page, right?
I live with him for over 2 years. We've been together since 2021.
I think the allegation about him bringing somebody up to his
hotel room is pretty integral and the implication is pretty clear
given that they've just spoken about pressuring girls into having
sex with them. And in my mind, you'll saying you're not sure
where they got the screenshot cuz it's extraneous. There are
so many screenshots here where you could have cropped them for
extraneous information to tighten this up. >> helped them
with this or not? Cuz this is like totally dispositive of anybody
with any amount of experience helping them because this this
question even in the format it's in does literally nothing to
prove that this >> Well, no, it's forcing you to commit
in a direction. It's completely incompetent on his part if that's
the case. On Mugen's part. It's incompetent on his >> It's
completely incompetent to suggest that this proves the above
paragraph.
>> Oh, yeah, I agree. Yeah, of course. So, do you >> Well,
I don't think anybody who's a big drama creator would do it.
>> Well, I think he would cuz he did the exact same thing
in his video. >> Oh, what did he say in the video? I don't
remember how he presented it in the video. I know that this is
literally not proof of anything. >> any of this document
during the video? >> Wait, but you're saying no, you're
saying he pulled the he's he read this and said we know that
he was doing this because she asked if he was doing this.
That is what you're suggesting to me. Is Mugen framed it this
way that because this question was asked, it's proof that he
did it.
>> Okay. What what is your question about Mugen's intent?
>> I'm saying Mugen would never do this cuz I assume that
if he's that big a YouTuber, he's not this that he would say
that this proves anything here.
>> I think this is to put an idea in somebody's mind. A
stronger implication than is actually sincere that there are
allegations swirling around about him trying to get V Tuber girls
up to his >> Yeah, hold on. >> The sentence after
there is an implication that he's pressuring people into sex.
>> They're claiming that directly. They are saying this.
So, now they're invoking somebody else. So, this is like when
Tommy C says that Nicholas DeOrio talks Chud Logic and he's a
total snake and this guy's Well, now I feel like if Nicholas
DeOrio doesn't come out and say something, somebody's invoking
his name.
Obviously, I know Nicholas agrees with that if he's not going
to say anything,
That this person is obviously going to come out and say I didn't
say that. If you're invoking a massive content creator and saying
she told me this, she told us this, right? That this is what
That is her word. It's Bow's word is yes, this is the this is
what people have told me about and I'll put you in touch with
some of them. That's what they're invoking here.
And this this DM does nothing to help that. This DM is just the
girlfriend asking if it was true that the tweet was about Saikou
no cuz the tweet is about somebody who does lore >> She's
not ideally asking it. Yeah, just talk. She's not ideally asking
it. This is to when somebody reads this what you're learning
is that there is an allegation this is going around and it's
not just them saying it. You don't have to trust them. Here's
somebody else reaching out in fact from out of the the ether
to say, "Hey, I've heard this. Is this true?" And then what is
cut out and this is after them saying about pressuring girls
and then and then there's something here about asking them up
to his hotel room. And then what is cut out is the fact that
this could be he said, she said, total rumor. I'm not sure. I'm
not even sure when or how long ago this was. It's just something
that the person that I heard it from, it's something that they
had just heard and so I'm coming to you. This is a fourth hand
rumor and you're saying that that doesn't impress upon you any
kind of difference.
No, none when they're objectively saying that after this they
had a conversation directly where Bow confirmed that it is the
case and that this was happening.
>> Okay, so you think that entire screenshot is totally
useless then? >> Yes. You could cut this entire screenshot
out of the document. It's just to show that yes, we are in contact.
It is something to show that hey, I was in contact with them.
>> No, it's not cuz you've got a more direct you've got
a I'm I'm telling you why why I don't think it is cuz if you
scroll down like 2 seconds >> a picture of like a horse
here with that would with like convince you that this is proof
and they're trying to mislead >> I mean it's it just is
what it is. It's not proof of anything. It's her saying, "I just
heard this rumor and I'm checking to see if it's like possibly
about my boyfriend."
And then she goes on to say that this is fourth-hand information
that she has and she's really not sure if it's true. And that
gets cropped out, okay? So what I'm saying with to you right
now is that this screenshot was >> Already a rumor. I'm
sorry to bother you with this, but I heard something recently
that was a bit concerning. It's already a rumor.
But it's how direct the rumor is to the first source the first-hand
of information or to the source of the
>> even know when this was or how long, but the person
that they heard this from heard this from somebody else. What
you're saying is that they included this to prove that they're
in contact with the girlfriend. That's not true cuz on the next
page we've got her saying, "I live with him for over 2 years.
We've been together since 2021."
So I'm saying, "What is the purpose of this, DeAnn?" And you're
saying it's purposeless. I've got no clue, no idea at all. >> I'm
telling you that it doesn't provide anything new. It is literally
showing that she asked Bow if the tweet if the tweet was true
or if it was true that the tweet was about Saikouma. And then
it's a screenshot 2 seconds later of her asking if it's true
that the tweet is about
>> It's under the wrong paragraph for that claim. >> I
I that seems to be the case for me.
Is that that is what it's showing. >> that this is You're
saying this is under the under the wrong paragraph and in fact
extraneous and shouldn't have been there at all cuz they've already
got proof like 2 paragraphs and I'm not sure why include this
in the first hand. And I think rumors are actually equal. Everybody
reads Everybody reads as if they're the exact same like level
of evidence. So it's clearly not how this >> after that
immediately immediately after that paragraph that I'm saying
that this should go with they say they called Bow. Saikouma's
girlfriend called Bow.
Called and Bow explained to her that other women had confided
in her about similar experiences. They're saying that this rumor
is true, that these these experiences are true, that these are
He described a pattern of behavior.
Bao then offered to connect her with these other victims.
So, this is literally saying it is obviously true.
What does this screenshot change? Whether how how does the certainty
of the girlfriend change anything about the situation if this
is true? If this paragraph is true. Sorry, I'm highlighting the
paragraph on my screen, but you can't see it. If the they called
Bao and explained to her, if that is true, which they're claiming
it is,
how does any the level of certainty of the girlfriend and her
certainty in the rumor or how you know, first hand, second hand,
fourth hand, how close the rumor was, how does that affect literally
anything when the next line then Sorry, the next thing that happens
after that message is they call and Bao says, "Yes, it was about
him. Yes, it all these things happened." Yes. >> Because
it's a second source of the
You're not only you're not only hearing that like trust me, bro,
people have told me this stuff. You've got somebody out there
who's saying I've heard this as well. >> Wait, I think
wasn't it like Bao was the person who was talking about this?
Like I think I think the impression I get is that people know
>> Is Bao the person talking about this? Who did the girlfriend
hear it from? It wasn't Bao. >> Bao was the person who
made this like uh
this tweet from the year before or whatever, right? Or from a
couple months before. That's about Saikouno. >> then when
you say that Bao is the person who's talking about this? >> As
in she's talking about Saikouno because of these instances.
That is what's communicated to me by the
She's been talking about Saikouno behind the scenes and how to
stay away like to stay away from him. Right? And so, probably
what the person said who heard the rumor was Bao knows. Go talk
to Bao. That's why the person goes to Bao directly and says,
"Hey, this is what's going on. He talked to me about it. Like
I I don't know what's going on. I heard a rumor, but you know,
people have said, you know, so I'm talking to you. Now, she didn't
say all of that. Didn't Bow also make the original group chat
that included the girlfriend? I actually don't know. >> I
think it says that Bow connected us, so that's possible as well.
Um but I got I'm not sure what this point like leads to. Okay,
Bow is talking about it. She's going to Bow for it. Sure. Yeah?
Listen, okay. To go down to go down
to go like like bedrock with that what I what I think our disagreement
is here. You think that the screenshot was provided here in the
wrong place for no reason. I'm positing a reason. >> No,
I'm I'm telling you
I'm telling you that you're positing that they are totally and
they don't understand cause and effect at all. >> How am
I doing that? >> Because this this message does nothing
to prove what they're asserting. >> To prove it? No. To
evidence it? Uh sure, based on the fact that all of this stuff
is going on rumors and [__] >> evidence it.
>> Cuz if it shows that not only is Bow hearing this stuff,
but these rumors are starting to circulate around.
>> Again, I don't think it shows that at
I think Bow had known about this. I think Bow was the person
circulating these rumors. That's why the girlfriend's going to
Bow. >> Wait, you think Bow was the person circulating
these rumors?
>> Uh um okay.
I guess >> Because Bow is literally referencing these rumors
and talking about them. That's the whole point of talking about
the tweet from a year ago. >> Wait, so you think okay.
Um that's like total conjecture, I feel.
>> She might be talking about this more explicitly behind
the scenes. >> Maybe she talked about it more explicitly
behind >> But I've got no idea why you're stating that
so confidently that Bow was the person spraying this specific
rumor behind the scenes
and not the person that was allegedly >> What I'm saying
is because it sounds like Bow was the person who she's big content
creator and people are going to her. She knows multiple people
like
Right? Multiple people with this story. This is she I assume
and hey, maybe this will all come out in the end cuz probably
there's going to be more questions, but why would she tweet this
if she hadn't known more than one person that this happened to?
>> Sure, she could know it, but what I'm asking is why
do you think that Bow is the source for the rumor that they're
hearing and not just somebody who is well known to be I don't
know calling out men in the space and people speculate this was
about Sykkuno. Why do you not think this rumor originated from
the person who's claiming they're invited up to the hotel?
>> I don't know who the rumor originated from. I know Bow
is the person who knows about the rumors and who is yes, speaking
up about men in the space and that probably that it seems like
the most likely thing that happened was the girlfriend is directed
to Bow because Bow knows about these rumors.
>> Yeah, knows about these rumors. >> And again,
and again, I don't understand. So, I'm just going to say it again.
Given that Bow is now saying, yes, I know about these rumors.
Here are all the women who have who have talked about this, have
said they had these interactions
and that's like broadly what they're using to source the idea
that they happened, that Bow told them about it. Right?
So, what again I'll ask, how does the the certainty of the girlfriend
with regards to the rumor actually affect anything else going
on here?
>> Cuz she's a secondary person speaking up to say that
she's heard the same things. >> But you how do you how
did people find out she was a secondary person? How did the girlfriend
know to message Bow? >> No, no, no, no, no, no. Secondary
is in the second person. You don't just have to trust Bow for
this
Recalling that oh, yeah, sure. Cuz it's um cuz this document's
been writing extensively by the hemo girl who's referencing what
Bow has heard from other people presumably with about Bow's co-signing.
Right? And this is proving that hey, yeah, this person presumably
as you say Sykkuno's girlfriend has also heard this stuff. >> So,
you're saying that Bow is That's the person who is >> testimony
to this possibly being true.
>> So you're you're saying about Okay,
But I don't understand where >> I'm saying this is the
most likely explanation why this has been included. What it's
supposed to communicate. >> Cuz you >> Oh, I >> You're
stuck by the fact that like this is a DM. It shouldn't have been
included here.
It has been included for kind of a perfunctory purpose.
>> Okay, hold on. Let's read the top of the >> If
you ditch that and assume that it was actually included for a
purpose and to prove something.
I'm I'm going to read from the top cuz maybe there's something
else going on
Just real quick. The coincidence that would lead me to finding
out the truth about Sykkuno happened last week. A popular male
VTuber tried to slide in my DMs to presumably get my pants, and
when I rejected him, he immediately started to mention nasty
rumors about Bow. Out of concern for her, I reached out to a
mod, who then connected me with Bow. The three of us struck up
a conversation. When I mentioned I was nervous about a date I
was going on, they asked me who it was with. When I said my date
was with Sykkuno, they immediately told me not to go on the date
for my personal safety. For my own personal safety. Bow told
me at the end of March, Sykkuno's girlfriend reached out to her
regarding a controversial tweet controversial tweet Bow made
last year. She asked Bow if the tweet if it was true that the
tweet was about Sykkuno. They called and they called and Bow
explained to her that other women had confided in her about similar
experiences with him. He described a pattern of behavior where
he targeted small female content creators. So, basically Bow
is now recollecting to Himemaru that Sykkuno's girlfriend had
just reached out to her. And that Bow was telling her about this.
>> Wait, wait, no. Okay. That's your reading of that. Did
you
>> What is your reading of it? >> My reading is that
his girlfriend is coming forward with with one of the rumors
that she's heard. And this is a second attestation or source
of these rumors, if you want to phrase it like that. You don't
just have to trust Bow. The girlfriend has also come forward
and been like, "I've heard this stuff as >> Oh, no, no.
I don't Yeah, I don't see it that way at all. The girlfriend
is literally trying to go to the source of the rumors. That's
what the girlfriend would do, right? She's trying to find out
who knows about this. >> the source of the rumors? What
evidence do we have that Bow is the source >> the not the
source. Not Not that like Bow I'm telling you that she knows.
She's trying to find who to talk to to figure out if this happened.
She's found her way to Bow. Do you think she is trying to find
who the actual people are who had this experience with her boyfriend?
Right? And so she has found her way to Bow who who's like a nexus
>> for these rumors.
>> And that is communicated perfectly by everything up
until this point. >> Uh sure. Yeah. >> Okay. So now,
how does that change how does anything change here given the
certainty of how certain she is about the rumor she heard?
But she's already uncertain, but if it was just slightly more
uncertain, how does that change anything?
>> Do you think that all rumors are created
>> No, but when they're also saying that Bow confirmed
those rumors to her. >> Okay, cool. So you don't think
that all rumors are created equal, okay? So if this is being
put forward before a second attestation for the fact that somebody
else has heard these rumors, the fact that I've heard this stuff,
I want to see if it's true, rather than I want to see if it's
true if I was
Um there's a lot of he said, she said rumors go around. >> Yeah,
none of that All of that is
All of that is implied to begin with. So I'm not fighting on
that cuz I I obviously think that to begin with. That's all implied
when I heard a rumor and I just I don't know if it's >> That's
not implied. It is not implied in that paragraph that she doesn't
know how long ago this was or even or even where it was.
There's a lot of key details of this stuff that she just does
not know. >> Is it being used to reference a specific allegation
she's heard? Is it being used to reference a specific allegation?
What What does her uncertainty about it >> About the veracity
of the rumor that she's heard.
>> Sure. Okay. Hold on. I think I figured this out.
So, she heard a rumor. We don't know if the specific rumor of
him pressuring women or of him getting women to come up to his
hotel room or getting women to have drinks, if we don't know
if the specific one she heard is true, but we also have no idea
what that rumor is. And then Bao has said, "Hey, I have multiple
rumors I'm telling you about now, and I will put you in touch
with all the women your boyfriend is like mistreating in some
way."
So, we actually don't know about that specific allegation. But
since that's not specific and it would never was specific, like
it's it's essentially non-specific in this as well, and she's
not saying she knows it's true.
What is the difference? Well, like I I just explained the difference.
>> So, she's not sure it's true, but she's heard it, but
she's missing a lot of key
And she's reaching out not as though she's got like core information
that she's heard, which would be incredibly concerning, but she's
basically heard absolutely nothing. When she reaches out and
said, "I heard something recently is bit concerning, something
with a hotel
that is literally all the information that she has." Yes, she
doesn't know when it happened or anything else. >> Yes,
but what does that change cuz then Bao says here's a whole treasure
trove.
>> The rest of the the rest of the message limits the scope
of what she has heard, right? So, in terms of this being a secondary
source of this information or source that somebody else has known
about this stuff.
It limits the scope of that and makes it less likely that the
rumor that she's heard is true.
Let's say the rumor she heard was false.
Let's say she heard something she heard that Saiykuuno actually
made these women
she Saiykuuno actually only talked to black Vtubers and got them
to write the on their breasts like Maru does, okay? Let's say
but it's totally fake, okay?
Yeah. Does that change the alleg- Does that change anything going
on here
I actually yeah, I don't know. We're like totally missing on
something. Maybe I'm looking at my chat. Maybe in my chat we'll
see what we're missing on. I don't know. They're trying to say
that we talked ended up talking about and the girlfriend, me,
Bao, and a few other women all got in a group chat and started
talking about how this guy lies. We realized he lies a lot.
That's like what this is all talking about, right? It's what
it's all leading
And it's using Bao as the source for the truth the truthiness
of these things. And so whether or not the girlfriend like the
girlfriend could have had a premonition. She could have seen
Charlie Kirk and a beekeeper in a dream just like Candace Owens
and they could have said, "Your boyfriend is cheating on you.
Go to Bao. Go to Bao."
it the story is the same.
>> Um I just I don't think the story is the same. I don't
I don't think the story is the same. Obviously been hyperbolic
with the like thing that you're describing. But if I were to
say, okay, if I were to say that I've heard rumors from a bunch
of women against Marou. Versus I've heard of women allegations
of a bunch of women against Marou and here's a screenshot of
somebody else who's heard those rumors and is coming to me. Is
that the exact same epistemologically the way that we look at
that the certainty we have over this over that stuff? >> but
then you say, "Hold on. Hold on." But then you you're leaving
out the next part, right?
You're leaving out the next part.
You're leaving out the next part which is then we went into a
call and this person confirmed to us that multiple women had
had this happen or have told Bao that they had it happen. That's
like the level of certainty we have here, >> That's not
proof to the public. You're just saying, "Oh, yeah, I heard this
as well. I They They confirmed it to me." >> Yeah, sure.
But I Hold on. So multiple people have So the attestation the
attestation is from Bao that multiple women have felt pressured
by this guy to have sex with them. I don't care. I'm not calling
him a I don't think this document proves he's a I actually don't
think it's asserted that he's a in the original statements. It's
not asserted anywhere that he like coerced these women into sex.
That's what Bow described.
This is not proving that. The proof is literally their word.
So, it's it's not like trying to use this screenshot to say,
"Oh, we have two women saying this." It's saying, "No, the girlfriend
heard something. She wasn't certain about it. She went to Bow.
Bow told her certainly that multiple women have reached out to
Bow and explained what happened with
That is what this section does. >> is the least interesting
point point of it. This screenshot is to prove that the the girlfriend
reached out to Bow. I just don't I just don't buy that. I just
don't buy that. Like, we take so much for granted over the course
of this document. I don't know why they would need to feel as
though they need to like go out of go out of their way to prove
that, "Oh, yeah, here's the message where she reaches out to
Bow."
Again, but this is Again, this isn't proving anything in any
way. They've already proved that they reached out. I'm not I'm
not saying that it's proving something, okay? To be completely
clear, I'm not saying under reasonable drama considerations,
okay, that this proves anything. I'm saying the optics that it
gives or the impression that it gives to the public.
So, I'm not saying how I'm looking at this as this as though
that gives like extra evidence to me, but I'm saying that's the
way that's being presented to the public. That might be our um
a disconnect there, I guess. >> I but I just don't think
so cuz you're saying it provides a disconnect to the public,
but in reality, the only thing that is different here the only
thing that is different is she was already uncertain, it was
a rumor, and then she goes, "But like I'm a little more than
just uncertain. I'm like really
about this rumor. But then, when she talks to the person, the
person goes, "All those rumors are
And you're saying the idea that she cut out the "I'm really uncertain"
part, it changes the story in some way. >> Uh yeah. >> Okay.
Yeah, I I think that's insane. >> I think that I think
the level of certain I think the level of certainty that somebody
has when they're bringing it bring it across the rumor leaves
like doubt that the story might not be true. >> Yeah, but
they're they're claiming the story is true and is is like more
than rumors and these are like first-hand accounts that Bao has
heard.
>> And this doesn't prove that at all. All it shows is
that the girlfriend was uncertain and so she reached out to Bao.
And I don't think this changes even if they include all of it.
And I literally don't understand how you could possibly think
it does. And I'm glad that Connor came around and like obviously
showed that it like it doesn't.
I don't know. I I've got a counterpoint to that. >> You
think that it's been you think that it's been cropped for
What's your alternative explanation, >> I I don't know,
but again Cuz I I feel like I have to explain to people that
if you crop something Google >> arguing for or arguing
for my motivation and do you genuinely not have one? You've got
no clue why they cropped it at all.
>> I it literally is irrelevant.
I it changes nothing about the story. They could have not cropped
it and I would have the exact same read on everything here. Would
you have a different read if they didn't crop it? On on how you
saw the document you'd have a different read on how you see the
document and the accusations therein if they didn't crop it.
>> No, again, I'm not talking about the way that I'm interpreting
this or how reasonable people should, but I'm talking about the
optics to the public and the way that it's presented. If you
include the second half, there's room for doubt there. She doesn't
know all the information and she thinks that it's a he said,
she said when she's coming to >> There's room for doubt
in the first
>> But it exacerbates the level of doubt,
>> It takes pains to explain the level of doubt. That's
my point, okay? With the way that this stuff is presented to
the >> Yeah, I don't I literally don't. >> the other
screenshots cropped?
>> I don't know. I haven't gone through them in the in
the document.
Cuz I'm seeing a lot of stuff where you still left in the messaging
stuff at the the at the bottom of the Discord screenshots. That
could be completely irrelevant if they just go and through and
uh
and uh cropping all of screenshots.
>> It could Would be curious, does Mujin's guide not talk
about the fact that when you crop something in a Google Doc,
it's not actually cropped and people can still see the full image?
>> Are you asking that knowing that it
>> No. I'm literally asking. Cuz that's like a thing I
know very well, and I assume most people who've ever covered
a Google Doc know that very well. And so again, I would wonder
why Mujin would leave it like this if they were trying to do
that. If a again, if he helped. >> Okay. Um but going back
>> Okay. Well, you think that you would agree though that
that would totally like degrade your idea that Mujin helped significantly
with the doc, right?
>> Um no. >> Like he would know that for sure if
he's covered a lot of Google >> I think that a lot of his
leaps here, I think that a lot of his leaps here and the way
that he phrases stuff is just unreasonable anyway. I think he
is going for an optical win over this stuff. Um so, yeah. >> Well,
I mean yeah, I mean he definitely >> We've got another
example so far. So, I think that he is going for optical wins.
>> Yeah, but he obviously would do that,
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. 100%. So, yeah, he obviously thinks Ichi Noe
is like a predator, right?
But I'm saying we're What we're saying is you could think he's
like a Sorry, like a Sorry, predator like as in he lied to a
bunch of these women to try
>> I don't think that Mujin believes he's got like strong
evidence for predation. I think this is team drama. >> to
me Sorry, I should say that's my definition of predation, which
I I said they shouldn't use that word cuz everybody else people
get really, really angry about that word. But I think he has
like a a system where he is like literally preying on women who
are smaller content creators by following
then reaching out, trying to do the same like connect each time.
He goes to all the hot women that are even remotely in his space,
and he just sees if he could get like some easy from them, right?
Now, it's not it's not people hear predation and they think it's
like >> Mujin reaches out to them first, or >> Yes.
I mean, from the other women on on Twitter and yeah. >> Have
they Have they shown the DMs? >> I'm not sure of a single
one that has. Yeah, there's a lot of women with cold opens. Just
go look for them. There's like at least three. Actually, in fact,
I think he sent the same cat gift to multiple women.
Did he do a cold open? >> Or did the little emoji? >> No,
like a tenor gif. >> Okay. As like an opener. Okay. Wait.
On Discord or on uh on on Twitter? >> On Twitter.
>> So, the allegation I think is that he like uh conversations
start on Twitter and then they move over to Discord at some point.
But, yeah. Okay. Wheeling back. So, the way that I'm looking
at the stuff, okay? Going for optical wins and there are cropping
that is happening in screenshots, okay? So, this is why I am
coming to this >> Here's why Here's why you think this
is cuz I think you started building a narrative at the very start
of your
And I think you've been building that narrative for a while and
I think you want to preserve that narrative. I think that's why
you can't let this go. To be honest with you. Cuz I I watched
this clip and it's very funny cuz you say he unfollowed these
people to not look like he was following them during the uh to
like paint the picture.
>> I didn't say that. >> You do say that. You say
that he refollowed them. You do a whole thing where you go to
his follow list and you like talk about how he refollowed them
because they now Now he's like he wanted to make the video.
>> You did that whole thing. >> it. He screenshotted
it when he wasn't following them, yeah.
>> No, you said probably refollowed them. >> I'd
have to go back. I'll accept that I said that. I'll accept that
I said that. >> And so, I was just like, well, that seems
silly when he says, "I'd like to thank the victims again for
trusting me with Like I I do
I do actually think he just made it very clear that he was talking
to them beforehand. And if he wanted to really like actually
make it obfuscated in some way, he would have like waited delayed
the video. He wouldn't have like released the video with the
Google Doc.
>> Um I think that he's been I think there's more than
that. I think there's more than that. I think he's had conversations
beforehand with these people. And I think they're products of
the document, in my opinion still. But >> Sorry, I get
this I get the implication. I'm pretty confident he talked to
them.
I get from this I get the implication that he's worked with them.
Yeah, I get all of those implications. That's what I get immediately
from his video. From from the comment where he's like thanks
to the victims for trusting me and the fact that he posted immediately.
I get all of that. >> That doesn't sound like he's working
with them. That sounds like there's a one direction that information
is traveling. That's from them to him.
What I'm saying is it appears though to me that he's like receiving
advice or they're receiving advice.
>> I understand that that's how you feel. Why then have
they made like so many clear mistakes with this? >> Well,
I don't think that Mugen thinks that these are mistakes. Especially
given the fact that Mugen's video completely backs up every point
that they try and build here. Every narrative structure that
they build here. He gives it in more detail in his video. They
feel like one piece when you read them. >> Yeah, yeah I
do that's that is literally what made me think like oh these
are working in concert. I think that's a part of it. Yes, I had
this impression the whole time but I didn't get the I never got
the idea that he was trying to hide it
Well, the way that he Okay, agree or disagree. The way that he
frames it is as though he's receiving information from these
people and he's happened to be given exclusive on this stuff
or happened to be however it happens to be, he's been given exclusive
on it. >> I don't know if he frames it that way but let's
say for the sake of argument he does. I just I don't remember
cuz I obviously haven't just watched the video. But let's say
he does.
Despite the fact that I think otherwise.
>> And the way that it seems reading through the document
is that he's had some kind of collaboration with this coming
through to the forefront, right? I think you said said these
guys have
>> Yep, that's what I think. >> He's acting as though
he's a commentator who's receiving this information, when actually
he has collaborated in the production of the document.
>> Okay. So, he's lying about his
>> Um well, I don't know if it's lying. Again, if you if
let's say Okay, let's say he is Let's say he's
even though he makes it very clear he was he had heard about
this, he had seen all the material way beforehand. Like, I think
that already implies that if you'd seen the material beforehand,
he would have pointed something out to them if he thought it
was like really a miss, right? He would never have just like
cover I don't think anybody would like cover it for an exclusive
and not say like, "Hey, you should adjust this thing." But Okay,
let's say he's
>> up the the way that he brings up the document, is he
framing this as the as though this is something else that somebody
else has written? Or does he give the impression that he has
helped kind of give feedback on the >> some something somebody
else has
>> Okay. So, he's claiming as though he's acting as though
he's receiving this >> If he did a significant
amount of work, he did a significant amount of work on this,
like significant editing, significant sourcing, significant anything,
then I'd say he is openly >> I'm saying like >> If
he had written some kind of
>> If he had If he had given more than just like a disclosure
of
Yeah, like if Well, hold on cuz we're going to get to the point
where Let's say hold on. Actually, let's do this first. Let's
argue. Let's say he did actually collaborate with them very significantly
and he's hiding that fact. Okay? Let's say both. Okay. What What
is your issue then at this point? >> The You've got an
alleged victim, self-described by their own words and by Mujin,
who has come forward and framed their allegations a very particular
way that they otherwise wouldn't have without Mujin Mujin's involvement
and that that is put his thumb on the scales of the drama.
>> Sure. So, do you think
in that case
So, you have no evidence for this, right? That he's pushed her
in a more dramatic direction. It could just as easily be that
he's pulled her back from a more dramatic direction. >> He's
pushed her Well, no, he agrees right up to the line. Uh I guess
it could be the other way, sure. That she responds to certain
arguments,
Uh all right. So, I I would say basically I would need to see
Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Just wait I'm just I'm saying I'll say
it first cuz then if you give me an example, it'll help it. I'll
just go, "Okay." So, I would need an example of something in
this allegation where you think things
are basically
where they are lying or where they make an allegation
where things don't rise to that.
I would need something in the document.
if it's not in the document, but it's in his video, I would be
concerned that he has different opinions than the people writing
the document and allowed those different opinions to flow. Would
we agree on that?
He has different opinions and allowed those to flow. Yeah, with
no pushback,
>> Like No, I'm saying Well, I'm saying that like if he
says something that's not in the document, I would say that's
a difference of opinion they have and he's not going to put words
in the mouth of these people to get it put in the
>> he doesn't differ from the document in that many places,
if any.
>> It would depend on the type of statement. Um it would
depend on the type of statement. Like for example, if um you're
describing um Hitler's Hitler's ambitions of invading the rest
of Europe and you say the primary motivation is A and I follow
it on saying, "Ah, it's an A with a combination of B as well."
That's a difference, but it's not a difference of opinion I'd
be describing, right? Yeah. Uh okay. So, I'm just I'm like basically
looking for essentially how did these allegations suffer because
of his involvement?
So, I agree that his involvement is a potential red flag, but
I need to know how these allegations suffered because of his
involvement. And I would like there to be some evidence of it,
but we might just be speculating,
>> Okay, so I'm not even saying that I've got evidence
that they have suffered as a result. I think that getting this
involved with the drama without disclosing that yes, actually,
cuz let's just assume that it happened, right? That he had some
kind of involvement and it changed the way the drama came out
or the claims that they made. I don't think you need evidence
to say that it would have been worse. You can just point that
out and there's a lack of disclosure and then that's the criticism,
right? Cuz you've got no idea how the document would have come
out in the first place.
>> Uh okay.
So, the fact that they messaged him at all, like I I agree, but
not because it makes sense or not because it made the allegations
suffered. I agree because people who basically have their own
agenda will push this in whatever direction they want it to go
in. So, people like Techtone will come along and say, "Well,
he convinced these women, he gaslighted them, he went and did
all this." Cuz obviously Saiykuuno did nothing wrong. But I do
think Saiykuuno did something wrong and I can just look at the
evidence that they lay out and I can I I I just I guess when
I watch this and I go through this, the message I get is not
about the faults of the people telling the story, it's about
Saiykuuno being like a lying
weirdo, like a lying degenerate, pathological lying degenerate.
That's the story I see. And I I I'm suspicious of anybody who
wants to make it about the people telling the story because without
like sufficient condemnation of the person who's like actually
doing the bad thing.
>> Um no, I think there's plenty of grounds to be able
to to be uh what, critical about the way that this like came
out. Um I think that anytime that you've got drama creators that
are this heavily involved with the people making the allegations
such that it seems as though there's evidence that there might
have been collaboration by your own like metric, that's always
going to be questionable, especially when you've got like what
is ostensibly a cheating drama, okay, from what we've seen on
the outside. To summarize it, that is what it is, right? >> And
then he's been described as a
>> by Mujin?
>> Did Mujin say predator in the video?
All right, cuz I I definitely saw
Sure, sure, sure. I just I literally wasn't sure what words he
used cuz I know that in in this document
the word predator is not in the document. Right? Or maybe it
is, but it's not in the initial allegations. Like the initial
allegations they lay out in this document
are the thing Yes, but the initial allegations they lay out in
this Google Doc. Like this Google Doc is well produced. If you
only read this Google Doc, I have like no issue with this Google
Doc. I think Sorry, I have no issue with like Like it proves
the allegations it sets to prove sets up to prove. The only problem
I'd have with it is it gave me a little extraneous information
that I don't care about. >> It It calls him a predator
several
>> Sure. I I Again and again >> I implore >> Go
on. >> So, predator. What is this in relation to? We'll
see. >> I implore the many other victims come out by their
experiences with this
>> Yeah, so this is after they talked to Bao, right? So,
again, there's like not very much. So, maybe the the criticism
we could have for this is that essentially they find out about
this cheating, they all freak out, and then there's some conversations
with Bao where there's no evidence of those conversations essentially.
Like what is actually said there, no voice recordings, no logs,
but they just say what happened with Bao, and then they say here's
where we >> With the >> So, it seems like without
without being able to produce the evidence of the things Bao
said other than saying what she said,
they've included like the their feelings about how like about
what Bao said and how it affected them. They include the idea
that he is a predator. He has women up has >> Is it whether
he's being labeled as a predator, right? Whether he's being labeled
as a predator. And you say that Mujin didn't call him a predator,
he did. And they didn't call him a predator >> I literally
asked you, did Mujin say
Cuz again, I said I didn't watch the >> thought there was
some disagreement on whether we had or not. Um I thought that
you said that he didn't, but okay.
Cuz it seems like everybody's calling him a predator off information
that maybe I'll hedge and say it's to yet yet to come out, okay?
Maybe it's all yet to come out. >> It just depends on what
you mean by predatory behavior.
So, as I mentioned in the intro, on No one made a public statement
before because they never had sufficient evidence. Saikou would
always talk to people in the most explicit and sensitive topics
or about the most explicit and sensitive topics on voice calls
or in person, never leave you paper trail. This is all intentional.
Rumors still managed to spread. Many content creators, both big
and small, would vent to their friends about this
Behind the scenes for many, he'd be known as a predator who regularly
took advantage of smaller or and or vulnerable create content
creators. The reason why Saikou would abruptly stop hanging out
with certain people throughout the years is because of this predatory
behavior.
So, the predatory behavior is basically trying to smaller content
creators. This is about Bao. This is the Bao stuff, right? That
she's got a bunch of these stories. We haven't seen that sourced
very well.
>> Yeah, I'm basically trying to look for like the way
Mujin would have affected
these rumors or these these allegations. That's why I'm asking
like what >> Would you say that a reasonable person looking
at this drama would describe Saikou as a predator?
>> I mean, it depends on how woke you are. >> Do you
think it's Do you think it's bad? Yeah, do you think Hold on.
Just like do you think it's predatory to consistently with a
pattern use a large platform you've built up to get like favors
from women with the obvious looming prospect like that they would
be fans of yours in the same space as you, the obvious looming
prospect of like if they set up collabs with you
they will massively financially benefit. Do you think that's
predatory
>> Uh no.
>> Yeah, so I I feel like there is some predatory element
there.
Well, no, no, no, cuz the the predatory element doesn't exist
that way.
It doesn't exist that way for other
Uh it no, hold on. How does this exist for groupies?
>> With bands.
>> You gain musical talent cuz you a musician? >> I
don't even know what you're what you're talking about right now.
You're going on something tangential. >> talking about
using your platform that you've built up to to farm your fans
for like essentially, right? By the way, I don't even this is
literally a question I've had I've been asking for like 2 years
now. Is like how correct is this? How bad is it? Cuz I see both
sides of the issue.
So, I'm not even saying that it is, but I understand people who
think it is.
I understand how it like chews people up and spits them out,
right?
I don't By the way, the hemo mall girl, I don't have this opinion
of the hemo mall girl.
>> The Okay. So, the people having
interaction with people in their same content creator space is
inherently predatory even if they don't actually kind of like
act upon the >> If you are the person who is trying to
to either initiate contact or get people to initiate contact
with you. If you're trying to essentially like cast a very, very
wide net. Consistently following all the small content creators
in your adjacent space.
Messaging them or letting them message you and slowly moving
it to Discord, trying to get closer to them and moving it towards
knowing that they were fans of you, looking for like I think
there is a thing there that can exist. Yes.
But I I don't know like basically if they look at Yeah, there
is a thing there that could be predatory. You could do something
predatory with this. And I do think it's very getting very close.
I think it's getting extremely close with Saikou no based just
on everything in this doc and basically what they're doing here
is they're taking the Bow stuff that they heard and they're including
in the doc without being able to source it very well. Right beyond
just saying Bao told us
And this is actually the reason I said it's bad to get close
to these kinds of things because you could technically believe
the people who are involved because you like them, because you
know
And the evidence might not be there for the claims, right? So
they've they've talked to Bao. The stuff from Bao is not in this
doc. We don't see proof of that in this doc. They just say it's
true.
Right? And if you if you knew that the stuff Bao was saying was
true, if you knew these women all had the similar experience
with him, were all smaller VTubers, right?
That that gives pattern. That gives like the same consistent
outcome happening. I do think something you could say something
predatory is happening. >> Well, that's different what
you you said to what you said earlier. So you're saying you could
do something predatory with that. And I think that I agree, but
it seems though you agree that inherently the thing that we're
describing here isn't predatory. >> I never said I never
said inherently.
If I said inherently, that was a huge that I don't mean it. >> We
were talking about We were talking about the dynamic. The dynamic
being >> Right? Yes, the dynamic they lay out
>> I said that it's not predatory. You would have to do
something extra to be able to leverage that, and it sounded like
you disagreed like 5 minutes ago. >> You'd have to do something
extra to leverage it. As in you'd have to say
can make you famous.
That would be predatory. It would require that.
>> Or it doesn't have to be to that extent, but it could
be, yeah, in kind, right? >> You'd have to take that dynamic
and then leverage it.
>> Okay. Did you read any of the Eric Swalwell stuff? >> Uh
Eric Swalwell?
>> Yeah, you don't >> I don't know that name. >> If
you don't know, okay. So he was a congressperson who had an intern,
like a 20-year-old intern.
if you have a relationship like that, so there's there's multiple
dimensions to this, right? Perhaps the opening of it is not predatory
in any way, right? But how does this person, let's say they actually
let's say they start collabing with Saikou no. And they're having
like some sort of dynamic there. How do they get out of that
pattern of collabing without professional harm?
How do they get out of like the >> Do they receive any
professional Do they receive any professional collaboration they
can move? >> Well, it sounds like these people play games
on stream. That is the impression I got, but I didn't see like
evidence of It sounded like there was some game playing on stream
with some of these >> Yeah, I didn't see any evidence of
that Which is why I'm saying, okay? >> I'm mixing it together
with the stuff I saw on Twitter. >> The dynamic as described
is not predatory to a reasonable person. It might be extra stuff
told by Bow, but that would be like a leveraging of it,
So, you could say there could be difficulties with this stuff,
right? >> I'm I'm saying that they have not laid out everything
for the predatory thing.
>> So, for Boston intern, that's going to be like by definition
inappropriate.
But for for it to be predatory,
you would have to have somebody leverage that to be able to predate
on somebody else. Things can be a conflict of interest
and be bad without it necessarily being predatory, right? >> How
is it How is it not leveraged
Like how how would it not be leveraged?
the person wants to stop. That That other person is their boss.
There is now a whole bunch of There's now a whole bunch of reasons
that you feel uncomfortable stopping this relationship, no? >> Uh
yeah, yeah, yeah. That seems like a Okay, conflict of interest
there. There's like difficulty. >> anybody who's in any
form of like position of power is unable to process that that
is the case? >> No, no, I understand, yeah, which is why
I say it's inappropriate. But it just cuz something's bad doesn't
make it
Yeah, I agree it's bad.
We're quibbling over whether it's
I think predatory requires intent. It requires a power difference
between you and somebody else to go after somebody in a vulnerable
position. >> But if you had a pattern of doing that, then
suddenly it becomes something different, no?
>> Well, no, no, no. The The pattern is evidence that it
is
Or the pattern might be evidence that it might be intentional.
So, if Destiny was meant to deal with men on the internet, okay,
the pattern is evidence that it's intentional.
The pattern isn't what makes it it intentional. It's like an
epistemological difference. >> Um Sure, sure, sure. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, sure. I have no problem with that. It's
it's not really um with with him, with Destiny, I actually think
he's probably better in terms of this specific thing than Cykunno
is, like by a mile. Like Destiny always made it very clear that
he was not I don't know. I think it's really like he doesn't
fit into this drama like at all. Like he always made it very
clear that he was not having um like a long-term relationship
with these people. No.
I was just pointing to uh I don't know, a pattern proven a proven
predation, but yeah. >> Well, yeah, but then it comes down
to like how aware are these people? How much of a problem is
it? Like basically, you have to argue that people are And so,
I guess my argument is like at this point it seems very, very
>> You just have to point out that there's no evidence
that these people received anything back from Cykunno. That's
all you need to prove. They can never be in the same space.
>> Cuz what you're talking about is it's predatory because
there's some kind of reciprocity. They're receiving something
back that at some point they might stop receiving back if they
terminate the relationship. And there was no evidence so far.
>> could it could be. It could be. I was just going to
I was going through So, basically, what I'm saying here is
I mean, this might be a totally different allegation. It sounds
more with this stuff. I'm I'm talking about like hypothetically
with these relationships. I think they get like it's right up
to the line where the content creator relationships, given the
like scale difference,
that can start to feel like almost inherently like bad.
>> I'm not talking hypothetically.
What I was saying initially is that I don't think that a reasonable
person can look at this document and the information presented
as is and call this predatory.
I don't think that I don't think that an average person, a reasonable
person would. Do you agree? >> Predatory. Again, >> There's no
evidence that he received anything back. >> Again, to me
when they said uh what what was my criticism of dangerous
It's like I I actually was like okay, I I can maybe understand
going for predator in terms of English, right? The problem is
it's got a connotation. When they said dangerous predator in
the
to me that implied that you were like in sort some sort of
physical, mental like harm was going to come upon you, right?
Beyond beyond just lying. Like I would say, you know, consent
violations, this kind of thing, right? Which I would say there's
no evidence of that in this document. >> Yeah, sure. >> Again,
I that's why I I get baited into defending this cuz I do think
like the word predator should probably work here, but I think
it's basically because of like some online connotation that it
doesn't really work here. >> What I am online connotation
okay. I don't know what okay. >> Like I Do you understand
what I'm saying in terms of like English? The idea that he's
got like a a hunting ground of sorts, the idea that he is like
at the apex of this thing, that he is like going out and and
following the same pattern over and over, like predating. It
it does feel like there is some sort of thing going on there
with only his concerns and none of their concerns. But realistically,
then you fall into well, probably all like um all like pickup
artists are predators. And while that is probably true in both
senses, you need evidence of that,
>> Yeah, I think that people mean a very particular thing
when they call them a a predator. Um but >> Yeah, so I
that was my criticism for the word was basically it's got some
online connotation, but I think it like it kind of works in an
English sense, but you probably have to give it up to the people
who >> I don't I don't think that it works. I don't think
that it works in a in an any sense, to be honest. I don't think
it's an online connotation. I think even offline in like real
life when people hear the word predator they usually think the
shark
or serial
>> An average person even not on the internet they say
rapist or pedophile. >> I think I think covering these
sorts of dramas has given me like sort of some sort of like um
different way of seeing it. So again I I had criticism for her
using dangerous predator her tweet.
But that's like it's me basically having to disconnect and say
I can see why people are upset but about this even though I think
it's like I don't super care about the word predator.
>> If I let's just say like down the pub or down the down
the bar or something. >> I keep saying I I listen listen
listen listen listen listen. Hold on. I I've actually tried to
lay this out multiple times. I actually don't like arguing this
cuz I know I'm like super outside of the norm and so I'm not
going to ever like win an argument on this. I just don't care
how the argument. So I I again you say it means this when they
say predator I would have avoided predator for that reason. I
disagree. I'm I'm basically saying I've like some minor disagreements
there but I don't really want to fight on it cuz I I understand
what you guys say and there's just no way for me to win. Even
if I even if I make a good logical argument um you can just continuously
go yeah but it sounds this way doesn't it and I'll never ever
win. So I like even if I had even if I prepared an argument for
this I can never win this. So it's like actually just pointless
have a
>> So okay. I just think that like when we're talking about
language we're talking about as received not as kind of like
uh I mean like linguistically possibly interpretated right? We're
talking about what is being
But anyway okay.
>> Big pronoun guy?
Yeah. Am I? What do you mean? >> I'm I'm just asking if
you're a big pronoun guys. Feel like that would be a very consistent
thing right?
>> I like pronouns yeah. >> I just feel like some
of it was like people have a preferred way of receiving those
things and how they receive those things was like a big topic
of conversation. Just felt like probably it's both sides but
it's it's fine. I would say when you're doing media, when you're
making an allegation, it probably is about how people receive
it. I would agree there. In this case, this kind of thing, it's
got to be all about how people receive it. But again, I think
to to me the irritating thing is is that these things feel really
like not important
to me. Like I I see the I can analyze the events as they're laid
out. I can analyze what's here and see how this guy was like
lying to multiple women, doing the uh oh like let's let's you
know get closer, let's have a relationship with no intention
of doing so cuz they're already in a relationship, right?
>> Okay. So, I'm saying that the the language that I think
for most people in the space, it seems as though you agree predator
wouldn't fit the allegation as it's described here with the evidence
shown, right?
>> Yeah, uh no. I I literally So, I will give you >> in
the space with internet people like >> If we say yes, it
will be received poorly. Yes, sure sure sure. It will be received
poorly.
Don't do it that way cuz it'll be received poorly. >> And
the
I would say 90 Would you say 95% of people on the internet are
going to hear that somebody's a predator and receive it a certain
way or it's going to color their view, right? >> Um yeah.
Uh maybe.
And so the >> The unfortunate thing is Hold on. The unfortunate
thing is You have to understand that tons of
are totally fine with calling him a predator based on an actual
understanding of the events here. Tons of these VTubers, these
female VTubers and female content creators are totally comfortable.
They're just outnumbered massively. But they it it's like on
the female side
the female content creators are totally comfortable with the
word predator to describe this behavior.
>> The female content creators are totally comfortable.
I haven't I haven't pulled the female VTuber content creators,
so I'm not sure. >> I feel like overwhelmingly outside
of like some very obvious um like pick me differences, they're
basically all comfortable and they think this is like really
really really and Saikono's basically like a monster for doing
this not only to his girlfriend but lying to all these women.
>> Well, yeah, yeah. Okay, it's like a a a a a big big
difference >> No, but they would they would describe this
sort of like
as as like predation like using your big platform to smaller
female content creators. They would describe that as predation.
That's what they describe it as. That's what they see it as.
They are being predated upon. >> Okay, I would I would
deny that he's using it. So, we'd go back to the I guess the
task at hand, but
possibly I could imagine that he's >> deny he's using his
platform.
How did he reach out to these women? >> Uh yes. Oh, well,
if you're saying that he's like sent them a message on Twitter
then by definition, but again, I would talk about like leveraging
his platform.
>> No, I I think he's using his fame, right? He's using
his fame to these smaller content creators. >> Uh sure.
>> It's like it's like a gay politician.
Let's say you're like a US senator and you work on some committee
and there's like a 20-year-old intern from another place, right?
Who who you want to you meet them in some committee or something.
You meet them there. You don't have an actual authority over
them, but they know you. You're like very popular senator. You
want to them. There's like a thing going on there where like
if you have no serious intention with them, they want to know
that. And if you lie about it, that hurts them, right? And so
women, when you lie to them about your intention, that actually
feels like predation. Like they're being lied to and and the
thing's been misrepresented,
>> Being hurt, yeah.
That's that's what I'm saying is is that's how women see it.
Okay. I don't know if I I I don't know if it's worth like sitting
here and arguing over like what women think about it. Um I'm
just not sure. I just don't I just don't agree with that interpretation,
but maybe. >> You disagree You disagree that >> use
the word predator. I agree. >> Did night.
Hold on. You do disagree that for in that situation I just set
up that if that senator like lies, let's say he's not married
but he's got like a long-term partner and it's not really in
the news and he lies and he cheats on them and he says, "Yeah,
we're going to we're going to get married. We we're going to
be like a political power couple. It's going to be awesome. We're
going to be great." Maybe not that part cuz I don't think that's
evidence in the DMs. But you know, we're going to be together.
It's going to be great. And then they find out actually they
were he was lying the whole time. You don't think that that is
them feeling And then you find out there's a pattern of him doing
exactly that with other women multiple times. >> Uh yes,
that's what I get. >> they were promised something? That
would be promising some kind of reciprocity that he's never intending
on delivering
Right? So he's using a power >> think the fact that they're
Sorry, I I said get rid of the being involved in politics. I'm
I'm saying don't get don't I said the professional thing. I said
cut that cuz it's not evidence by the
Leave that part out. Just hey, we're going to be together. It's
going to be
I don't think so. Outside of like a hyper Tik Tok space, um the
fact that like celebrities in general would have sex with like
non-celebrities,
uh I don't think that I don't think that outside of very particular
area of Tik >> Like there's a very different thing going
on here. Sorry. Where being close to somebody by itself
is an access to their power as a Can't look at the Kai Cenat
situation and not tell me that just being the partner of somebody
in and of itself can be leveraged into a massive career. Especially
when they're a huge streamer. >> it has to be intentionally
leveraged in a separate way.
What if the politician has no intention of ever giving that person
>> what I'm saying is >> The politician never makes
it clear. >> You're misunderstanding me. You're misunderstanding
me. So what I'm saying is that if you have if you're a secret
girlfriend in the background, okay, right. Yeah, that's never
going to come to fruition for anything. But yeah, they have to
be on stream. There has to be some kind of like actuation of
that.
>> Cuz otherwise who the [__] is going to know
about you? The reason why few more streamers pop up where they
got a [__] girlfriend. >> We're going to live
together. We're going to be together. This is going to be we're
going to you and me together >> Because in the streamer's
place, you have access to that person's platform because you're
able to get your name out there through them given the fact that
you're like dating them. >> saying that's implied by the
idea of being like long-term monogamous >> It could be
sure. Yeah, it could be implied that there's some kind of action
there. Yeah, okay. >> Okay. So, that is being leveraged
in
when he's offering when he's saying we're going to be like an
actual long-term monogamous couple. He's using that repeatedly,
or at least in two instances, but they say they have more instances,
and it seems like some people backed up the idea that he was
like doing that kind of thing with other people. Now, it's it's
murky, but to me if that's a a pattern of him saying we're going
to be, you know, a long-term thing, we're going to be together,
and then he meets them to met one con. It I don't know what's
going on with this guy, by the way, cuz it seems like as soon
as he sees women, they leave on their own. I don't know what
the [__] that is. That's rough, okay? That's rough.
So, I but I think it's just like an obvious It's like an obviously
bad thing, and I see why the women don't like it. I see why the
women think of it as like as predatory behavior. And I It makes
total sense to me. I I think it's like it's actually just really
hard to solve the problem. Cuz unfortunately, the both sides
of that equation are going to want that to happen. They're both
sides of the equation benefit from that. >> Both sides
of the equation are going to want to >> Yeah, like women
women will want that predation. Women literally will want that
predation until it goes badly for them. Until they find out they
were lied >> predation until it goes badly. >> will
want the idea because the solution is don't date people in that
thing. But women do want to be able to date like people who are
more powerful in the same field than them, right? Cuz the prescription
is if that is inherently predatory, the prescription is >> in
the streamer's place. >> Yes, and they might and again,
that is either intentional or unintentional. Like it could be
totally unintentional.
So, how do you even You can't really do anything about it. It's
like a complicated problem.
Yeah, sure. I just say there's like a an assumption of risk there,
yeah. >> Anyway, um yeah, again >> I think that's
the way that you solve it, no? >> Uh maybe, but then unfortunately
there is there is unfortunately the the age gap starts to come
into into effect there.
You're When you're talking to a lot of girls who are 18, 19,
and I'm not saying he's a I don't think he's a But like obviously
there's just some crazy thing that happens that these guys become
rich and famous and they all want to 18-year-olds. It's like
crazy. Can't explain that, I guess. >> Nicky, the money
doesn't >> think women are most attractive when they're
like 28, okay?
But these guys, they get all the power in the world and they
just want to like 18, 19, 20-year-olds. Crazy.
Anyway. Sorry, it's >> joke, obviously. But um that that
actually does come into play. The age gap comes into play. The
fact that she doesn't have experience comes into play. And the
person with more experience and all the power there should be
the person who can not take advantage of it. The person who does
temper themselves a little bit, who doesn't explicitly take advantage
of it in the exact way he knows he's never going to like actually
fulfill or follow through on. >> Take advantage in the
exact in the exact way that he knows he's never going to um >> Is
in offering the long-term
and knowing he is never following through on that. >> Um
wait. Didn't you say earlier that you don't think that he was
being sincere. He was being flirty.
Oh, but you were saying that he should have should have disclosed
that he wasn't being serious about that, right? Okay, yeah.
Okay. I can see the argument there. All right. Um
I mean, bringing it back to what we were originally argued about,
sorry. It's The conversation has meandered and I'm 99% sure that
it's absolutely on me.
so it sounds like you broadly agree that Mujin has underplayed
his involvement in the situation while covering it. You see that
as a point of criticism. I see that as a point of dishonesty.
But you just don't think that it's been leveraged in a negative
way.
I don't think that cuz I didn't get the the understanding that
didn't hit me at all when I covered this. I covered it yesterday,
right? Like I covered it yesterday. I didn't see that at all
that he was underplaying it, like at all. I I don't even think
the message is underplaying it. When I hear that, I'm like, oh,
if he knew about this beforehand and read all the stuff beforehand
and prepared his video, he had his narrative for his video, he
had full access to these people to talk to them. Obviously, he
would do that. And that that could mean to me, that implies everything
up into up to and including like edits on the document, like
him providing his opinion on the document. I I assume that immediately
when somebody says they're involved ahead of time. >> They've
co-written or edited the
>> I would say co-written, like and maybe he just Have
you tried tweeting at him? Maybe he'd just answer. He's been
answering a lot of questions on Twitter. Maybe just say like
what his involvement
I just I would just try to ask him, see if you could find out
what his involvement was cuz I personally, I'm just like
I don't see anything Nothing to me here seemed like it was really
that well laid out. Like I saw a lot of editorial issues with
this, a lot of like fat that was left in for no reason.
so I again, I I didn't get the impression that he helped like
a ton with it. Maybe some edits, maybe some
But if he, you know, straight up wrote it with them or straight
up gave them pointers on how to make things more dramatic, I
mean, that maybe he wouldn't even say that cuz that would probably
be like career-ending for him, but I I don't I haven't gotten
that impression. This seems like very in line every single VTuber
drama I've I've covered. Like the way that the way they're hyperbolic
and overly dramatic, it's been very very very similar the whole
way through.
I've not gotten the impression that like this had a drama YouTuber
making it like amping it up or or like that.
And I I would I would suspect that if anything, given again that
they're Vtubers, this girl's 19,
they're extremely performative, if anything he might have pulled
them back would be my expectation. But, Um, okay.
>> And you're aware that he's been described I don't know
if I brought this up earlier, I actually can't remember.
That she's she's described him as like a confidant during the
drama.
>> I Yeah, can you send me that tweet? I think it's in
Well, hold on, I think it's actually in your clip. Give me a
The pup still Yeah, I do. See.
Uh, you pull it up here somewhere.
So, me and Muxin have been friends and he has been and has been
one of my confidants in this entire time. On top of that, predator
doesn't mean pedo. Do you think if he was trying to downplay
it, he wouldn't have told her I'm trying to downplay it? >> I
don't I don't think this is like an intentional conspiracy. I
think that he went when he goes to go and record his video, he
doesn't like do it's it's a lie of omission. It's a failure of
>> Yeah, I I guess we just disagree cuz he literally disclosed
that he was like that he was trusted with this. Literally trusted
with this and confidant are essentially synonyms. >> Um,
is confidant not somebody that you talk through your issues with?
A confidant is just somebody you talk to about your
>> A confidant A confidant is somebody you talk to and
they say, "Oh, that really sucks." Like and and they talk to
you about it. Like, they're somebody who is in your confidence,
right?
>> Uh, sure. >> that you trust in them. >> there
that you're like talking it through with them?
>> Yeah, I don't think that's not implied by trusted me
with this. Like trusted me to bring this to me and handle this
this doc drama with them.
>> So, he's gone through and he's like been discussing
this stuff with them previously before the documents like written,
before he's handed the
>> I Like up to and including that, yeah.
And basically, the thing I would say is I would need some evidence
of how his
basically overplays what they wrote or overplays what their allegations
are. And to me,
I can understand where they're coming from. I understand exactly
why it won't work for them.
But like the using the words predator. But I again, I understand
where it's like coming from and I don't think it's even necessarily
like
uh in the exact way I described given what they've laid out.
But that's me assuming that when when the Bow person tells them
this story, that it that those stories like people did come to
them and say, "Hey, this guy pressured me and all of this." It
might come out that actually she heard one story and she said
it was way more and actually that story is really flimsy and
and her and Saikou no still talk like the girl who went up to
a hotel room or something. But I mean, in terms of my impressions,
I'm fine with like trusting that right now.
Cuz again, I don't like I'm I'm trusting it in terms of that's
why they're calling him a predator and that regardless of how
consensual or non-consensual like, "Oh, he they got me drunk
and brought me up to a hotel room or something." Like I'm not
making judgment there and calling him
But it's like that there's a pattern of of going after smaller
creators, trying to smaller VTubers, people in that same
I just don't doubt it cuz I've already seen like 50 DMs on Twitter.
Okay. Um so
>> If you if you if you see commentary channels getting
intimately involved with the drama with other people such that
they get an exclusive,
you would you would never Okay.
I just I I I feel surprised by your by your lack of character
and integrity. >> Well, I think so I think basically
nobody cares about disclosures and they'll just bring it up later
anyway. Like as an example, when the stuff happened with Destiny
in January, it was very obvious. People asked me, "Hey, aren't
you biased here?" And I said, "Yeah, that's like a person I've
been super close friends with for like a year and a half now
who was the the co-host of my stream for like 8 months. Like
every single day for hours and hours and hours a day.
>> But people still bring up me and say that I didn't disclose
stuff and it's like it couldn't have been more obvious, but go
ahead. >> Uh I think there is like informed I don't know
views of a drama you could you should care about disclosures,
>> Yeah, so when I when I read that that Thank you for
trusting me with this. >> a documentary about Destiny and
it collaborated with him for the entire
right? But he doesn't appear in there and it's like you know
>> Thank you for appreciate Thank you Destiny for trusting
me with this.
Yeah, that's enough of a disclosure for me to go wait, what did
you guys do here? Which I think you've gotten here. >> You
know what I just want to say you know what disclosure about the
fact that there has been editorial if there has been editorial
processes over it.
>> I don't so again, I assume it's up to that line.
And I just I think you could literally go and ask him. If you're
If so, that's the thing is basically I think and everybody does
this and it's the laziest thing in the world. So don't, okay?
Just go ask what what involvement he had.
He literally disclosed that he was a part of it that he was trusted
with this ahead of time. He didn't try to hide it. And if you
think he had more of a hand and this up somehow, then just ask
what his process what his involvement was. >> Okay. Um
yeah, sure. >> by the way, if that's not on the record,
>> But it seems like you don't think it's >> now,
then you're never going to catch him in a lie later.
>> No? Cuz you said >> I think it's up to that line
when he
when he says trusted me, I would assume it's up to. I don't know
what I find lucky or sorry, what I find likely. I don't know
why I said lucky. I don't know what I find likely cuz this is
written really poorly and I just think if he was involved, he
would have helped him write it better.
>> Yeah, but you
>> Do you not Do you not find it >> kinds of mistakes.
Do you not find it odd that he doesn't distract from the narrative
a jot?
But there were no bits here Reese is like, I don't think that
claim is true. >> No, but I think this is their side of
the story. I literally think this is I don't know how you could
do that. He he clearly isn't even attempting to do Did he reach
out to Sakuuna for comment? Did he go to Sakuuna and say, "Hey,
here's what I know and are you going to Like it's not even presented
as as their side of the story or sorry, like a an even-handed
thing. It's presented as I'm presenting this side of the story.
It's
how would I even describe this?
I think
it's it's literally not presented as like their side of the story.
Sorry, it's his side of the story. It's not presented as like
even-handed. It's presented as these people are doing this doc.
I'm going to go through this doc. >> And so if he gets
criticism for it later if it turns out that it's not true, is
he just going to say, "Well, I was just presenting their side."?
>> No, he's totally for being involved early. If if it
comes out that like this wasn't looked into or fact-checked,
he's totally
I'm saying that in terms of my analysis, I've got no problem
with him as long as he crosses his t's and dotted his i's and
he's made sure that he'll stand on these allegations.
Yeah, he's totally he's totally committed his his reputation
to this.
If you're just saying that's a bad idea, then I agree and I made
that criticism.
But I just don't see anything that's actually up in the document
or his video yet that I'm like, "Oh, you really this up because
you were too close to it." >> Do you not think Okay, I
Have you yourself not said that the claims the claims in are
excessive?
Well, no, you haven't >> I've said that the tweet is excessive.
I've said I've said that I understand the usage of predator the
way they're using it, right? Based on what's happened with the
the Bow stuff, but of the original claims at the very top about
him being a a liar, a cheater, a manipulator, I think those are
all true. >> Okay, so you also think that this guy is a
sugar daddy? >> Uh, yeah.
Do you not think he's a sugar daddy?
>> No. What? >> He's a total HE'S A TOTAL PAY PIG.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> I said Okay, so I said that during my coverage as a
joke, but a sugar daddy is somebody with a more formal arrangement
than this, surely. If you're like >> No. No. No. No. No.
No.
They They Maybe they should have said pay pig. Maybe they should
have said that. But >> there has to be some kind of communication
about that on during the during the [__] content,
no? Or during the discussion together? >> I don't think
that needs to be any kind of explicit No, I don't think that
has to be any kind of explicit relationship. I You're reading
this in like a way where you want to find fault.
Sugar daddy and he randomly has He randomly sends money to all
of these women, offers to pay for everything. I don't think that's
weird at all.
What do you What is the What is the like actual negative about
him being a sugar daddy? What is the allegation of sugar daddyism?
What is this?
>> There's a quid pro quo for money for
That's what a sugar daddy is. >> Uh no. No. No. No. No.
That's literally not what a sugar daddy is. Tons of sugar daddies
get no favors. The [__] are you talking about? >> Yeah,
but he is getting favors. So, what's the allegation, though?
Also, I'm not even saying >> them a bunch of money. It's
literally not It's literally not like a harsh criticism. It's
not anything like that. What is the negative What is the downside
of him being a sugar daddy at all? He's like a pay pig. They
They were nice about this.
Like a totally degenerate pay pig who just throws money at women
without them asking. He just likes the idea of showering women
with gifts. >> Is this not part of the manipulation? That
he's manipulating them by sending them money. >> I mean,
it probably is a part of the manipulation. It's just not something
that I think they didn't want. And I think presenting it in the
document as something Oh, I didn't really This was like so [__]
up. It's goofy as [__] Yeah. Okay. But it is a part
of the manipulation. It's without a doubt a part of the manipulation.
No? >> Okay. Um all right. >> Are you more or less
likely to [__] somebody if they give you a bunch
of >> You're more, but is that manipulation?
>> Yes. You are reading You are reading
You are negatively loading manipulation. It is him doing an act
for an indirect benefit. He is indirectly acting in a way to
get something out of it.
>> You can't What do you mean a neutral loading or manipulation?
Manipulation is necessarily negatively loaded, Jay Stowe. Come
on.
>> Okay, so it's it is literally underhanded in that he
wants but he's going to buy them video games. That is the manipulation.
He wants so he's going to buy them video games instead of just
saying I want That's the
>> He's like He's like buying them gifts,
Okay, he's like saying >> Manipulation is is literally
like masking your intent, what you actually want to happen, and
doing something else to produce the result you want. Yes?
is usually underhanded, but sure.
That's happening here. I just don't think that's That's like
unfortunately
No, yes, it is. It is. It is. The thing that's throwing you off
is that this is a totally normal thing that people do all the
time. People will manipulate each other's each other in relationships
all the time.
>> So now we're talking about well, he is being manipulative,
but only in so far as people are everyday manipulative.
>> Is it Okay. So you're saying that in a totally morally
neutral sense, he is manipulating them. But you understand that
that's not the way in which they're alleging it. So when I say
>> Yes, I think they're clearly retroactively negatively
loading this because it was something they liked and he was using
it to get out of them and they don't like it later.
>> You're saying yes in a different sense that they're
alleging it.
So you don't agree with their
>> I agree that they were manipulated. I don't think it's
like a weird thing and I also don't think they're going he's
a sugar daddy and like that's so evil. That's like Is it are
sugar daddies evil? It's just a part of the broader manipulation
to get in these people's pants. The That's why it's not in the
in the tagline. That's why it's not like
What's the What's the negative allegation about Can you explain
to me what No, no, no. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's a sugar
daddy line. I have to I have to ask you this right now. There's
a sugar daddy line in the same format as the line. What is the
negative manipulation the allegation about Oh my god, he's he's
evil. These are set up in the exact same way. They're the headers
of a section. >> Well, I can tell you that it's contrary
to his stream >> Oh, yeah, but it is. >> That's negative
implication.
>> Sure. Yeah. >> Well, then so you would agree that
>> Would you agree that where he cuts away from his where
he is like cutting away from his stream persona that that's like
Oh, also I I don't even think he does it
Okay, hold on. I just need to be right back. I have to go to
my door. 2 seconds. You you you you can talk. I'm sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. I'm not I'm not me to fight on everything, but I think
this is all fine. I don't think this is weird.
>> I think that So, we were just arguing about whether
there's negative loading. I'm assuming J still can hear me right
We were just arguing about whether there there is negative loading
on it. It's an argument that not all of the chapters have negative
loading. There's a question about whether the this has negative
loading. It does, okay? And so, I think that the sugar daddy
stuff also has negative loading. Um I don't see that this is
a I think this is a forced allegation. I don't think it's manipulation
in a negative way at all. Um in the way that like buying a gift
for somebody that you're starting to date or like court
is like manipulative. Um I think that it endears you to the person.
That endears you to them. But I don't think that it's underhanded.
And I don't think that it's um in a negative kind of way. You're
You're dating the person. You're like stating your interest up
front. It's pretty clear what you're doing. >> It is, but
I just have to grab water real quick. I'll be 2 seconds.
>> Couldn't one thing that may be normal be a part of constellation
and then it becomes bad?
>> Hold on. That is basically the argument we're going
to do, but but there's a better way to lay it out. So, all of
these things
Sorry, but you're going to answer that question for your chatter.
You can do that first. >> It was royal, so it's uh it's
your guy. Go on. You lay it out. >> Oh, so the way I see
it is all of these things done genuinely are like manipulative,
but they're understandable. You have like feelings going on.
People aren't trying to be evil. The thing that makes this bad
is that he's engaging this pattern at the same time with multiple
women while telling them they are the only one he they're talk
he's talking to, while telling them that he is single, while
telling them that he does want something long-term or something
more permanent with them. While knowing that is a lie.
The idea of love bombing is stupid um in that most people love
bomb in relationships because they really care about the other
person. When you are doing it disingenuously, knowingly disingenuously,
that is what is [__] up. That is what is a manipulation.
That is what is predation.
okay. What let without getting into argument with the predation
stuff cuz we Yeah, we already looped around on that and you said
you don't want to argue about it. Um I think that just loops
back to a cheating allegation, right? So, you are making a cuz
what would be like a fraudulent misrepresentation if we want
to go like really, really precise. You're like lying about, you
know, being open to be able to date when you're not open to a
be able to date. >> That you're you're totally wrong that
it's just a cheating allegation.
>> No, no. Okay. Okay. Wait. Didn't you Didn't you agree
earlier when I said broadly, this is just a cheating >> If
I did, that was stupid because the lies are actually as significant
>> Okay. Sure. But do the lies not go to the cheating?
>> No. Who is hurt by the lies here? The girlfriend who's
being cheated on? Or the person Can you cheat without hurting
somebody with the person you cheat with? Can you cheat and they're
totally fine with it? >> Um you you you can if you're up
front with it, yeah. >> Obviously yes, right? Obviously
yes.
But he's not doing that. He is engaging in cheating in a way
that's going to hurt another person. And so these lies should
be disconnected from the cheating alone because these lies are
a different pattern of behavior and they are a pattern of behavior
that need to be isolated from just the cheating, the harm he's
doing to his girlfriend. He's doing harm to other
He's doing it while he's cheating, but these are a pattern in
and of themselves that that like in a it's a pattern in and of
itself that needs to be analyzed, this manipulation he's doing
>> I put that I put that in the bucket of uh I put that
in the bucket of uh cheating. He's lying in furtherance of the
cheating.
It's in the behavior of cheating. In the course of conduct of
cheating, he's lying. >> But but then so I would say that
would be fine. >> when I say it's only it's cheating >> Yes.
But if I say hold on. >> hasn't got a girlfriend. >> If
I say if I say this person's a
what impression do you get? >> Um that cheating on the
girlfriend.
>> Who's the victim? Are there are there a dozens of victims
potentially? >> Uh primary victim's the girlfriend.
>> There really are no other victims implied by cheating.
>> Well, usually people aren't open about the fact they're
cheating.
Are they?
They might be, but even then a lot of I would say a lot of cheating
happens in either ways that they are open about it because the
person knows them well enough to know So like one one subsection
would be like the work wife that you end up right? So that person
knows that they're cheating with you. People are often very open
in that situation. I say this is the most common
>> I think the implication that when somebody's cheating
is that there's going to be the other woman who also does not
know that the guy is not
No, I don't even think that's remotely
Do you do you not think the most common set like sets of cheaters
are people who do know each other for a long period of time,
get entangled, would know that somebody has like a wife or significant
other and anyway?
That's got to be it, right? >> There's a You're saying
there's a there's a significant portion of people
who know that somebody else has got a long-term partner and would
still get involved? Yes. No.
There's basically tough The people you most are the people you're
proximity to. Obvious Obvious truth. >> Um For an ordinary
relationship, yes. For cheating, I think people try to obscure
that. >> Not for a Not for a daddy Dom Dicker's relationship,
but for most people, yes, exactly. Thank you.
>> They're going to >> to They're going to be Okay,
somebody
>> What do you mean not for a cheater? >> We Are
you going to Okay. You Carry on Carry on with what you're saying.
>> Do you want to say that like the If you engage in a
pattern of cheating, you're defined as a cheater. Usually, you
do it by lying to people most of the time.
>> I think that if you're cheating on your partner, you're
not going to have sex with somebody in the same um in the same
kind of like area. Like close friend. >> A thousand percent
not Now, I think that's actually just totally blighted by >> And
the people people have sex with people who cheat who know that
they already have a partner.
>> That Yes, this is one subset that is I think the probably
the majority that they would know this. But there's another subset,
which is probably another significant like chunk, which is people
who are having like one-night stands. They go to a bar, they
get drunk, they somebody random.
>> I would say that's the majority of >> Okay, but
then there's not another victim. So, in both of those cases,
probably 95% of cheating, the the person who they're cheating
with is not a victim in any way.
>> Yeah, so it's not There's not necessarily Okay, there's
not necessarily somebody else, but is implied that there could
be, okay?
I mean, this is all about like what you do to me is playing the
victim. >> it's it's essentially sweeping under the rug
the actual bad behavior on Sakuno's part here. Like sorry, not
the actual bad behavior cuz obviously, whatever he did to his
girlfriend is [__] up. Sorry, there are two sets
of bad behavior. I shouldn't minimize that cuz he's probably
really his actual girlfriend up a lot. But there is another subset
of victims. There's another like set of victims here who are
actually important and this guy is with. And basically, everybody
wants to ignore that they exist and everybody wants to say they're
overreacting, and guys are dogs, and this just happens to everybody.
And I'm like, "No, I don't excuse this guy being a lying, degenerate
piece of that. No, he's a total piece of especially given his
stupid extreme personality, which I hate. I've despised this
guy from the second I heard him speak, okay? So, I'm not going
to let it >> Oh, yeah. This guy's a piece of >> I
heard this guy talk to like Pokimane in Valorant once, and not
to him, but to his teammates that weren't Pokimane, and listening
to like difference. Oh my god, this guy's a piece of You can
tell. You can tell. I can tell instantly, all right? This guy.
But, you know, obviously still look at the drama in a pretty
even-handed way, and I I do think that there's something bad
happening that I can call out. And I I don't know why it feels
like everybody has this inclination to minimize it. And I don't
get it outside of it feels male-female like like gender war stuff.
Like basically men are like, "Oh, I don't want to be accused
of being like a predator cuz I accidentally like love bombed
somebody I was really I really cared about." It's like, "Dude,
that's not a problem for you for one. Like if this was sincere,
I would have no problems with Sykkuno."
He was just like a loser who was like way over the top with women,
and but he sincerely was like chasing one at a time, telling
them, "Hey, you're the only person in my life," and he wasn't
lying about it. I would have no problem with it. >> Um
okay. Well, if that's going to be like a problem in the conversation,
I'm saying that I'm not giving my takes cuz I'm going to be concerned
at some point that somebody's going to come forward and make
a cheating allegation against me. Um If that's your If that's
your point of concern. >> Sorry, I don't think it's like
a very conscious thing. I think most people are like pretty unconscious
of it.
>> Okay. So, this that's what I'm doing subconsciously.
Okay. Um >> I Dude, I'm not I'm not like talking about
you. I think this is most of the people on Twitter. You're like
a reasonable person. I'm saying most of the people on Twitter
are like this.
>> Okay. Um I'm saying that the story is probably been
like massively oversold by the way that it was first advertised.
And so when people are looking under the hood, it's like, "Okay,
this is not what I was necessarily sold."
Yeah, I think Do you not think this Wait, do you disagree that
it obliterates his stream personality? Predator. Do you not think
this obliterates his stream personality?
Just these Let's say we could retitle
It totally destroys his stream personality. No, I'm not talking
about the effect on him as a streamer. I'm talking about the
moral impropriety. Do you Do you not think that people are sensitive
to the term predator?
>> Yeah, they are. >> Yeah? And so when somebody
is described as a predator, do you not think that that's like
a big check to cash? >> It's like literally >> probably
looking at the streamer and thinking, "Damn, this guy's not a
>> Um I don't think people come away thinking he's not
a predator cuz we're not there yet. I think in 5 years I'm going
to be completely vindicated on like this precise pattern of behavior
is like predatory. >> No, no, no. You're talking about
the public reaction now, Jist. Don't mean by 5 years later.
>> I think people are broadly overreacting to that to the
word predator and not reading the actual allegations and letting
this guy totally off the hook for some degenerate behavior.
>> I think that it's an insanely high bar to cross to call
somebody a predator. Not that it's like hard to prove, but the
actions need to be like pretty severe. We're talking about some
kind of
I would say. >> So, I wouldn't call him a predator.
I don't think they should have done
I'll agree with They shouldn't have done
I don't But I'm telling you, okay. >> essentially a nothing
burger. But the way this is presented is incredibly high >> So,
here's my Here's my take that I put out on Twitter. Dangerous
predator, too far based on the evidence. That being said, I've
no issue with someone who has a long-term pattern of lying to
women to get in their pants being exposed for it. Sykkuno's a
piece of [__] Good to know.
You disagree with any of that?
>> No, I agree with
And all right. >> And I think I think people trying to
take away from the actual focus, which is Sykkuno, are doing
it because they would rather focus on um how like me too that
they're like lesser tech tones. They're all just lesser tech
tones. They'd rather focus on like the me too element than the
huge creator who's like a total piece of
>> Um I think that even if that is the case in the public
sphere, I mean it's the problem the person presenting me allegations,
right?
>> Sure, but then what if they just change it? What if
they What if they post and they say, "Predator was a little too
far. I'm going to say serial cheater, master manipulator."
>> Um I'd say serial cheater >> awesome. Everything's
great, right?
>> Yeah, I think the way that you present stuff is like
important to a public reaction. Yeah.
>> You think these two words
should be determinative of how you receive this entire Google
document? And the two words two or three times they put it in
the Google document at the >> on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on. Cuz the way that you're framing the question
now is not the way that we were framing it before, okay? So in
terms of the public backlash and talking about the story, this
is meta-commentary about the Google document about the drama,
right? You're saying that it's unreasonable. I'm saying that
somebody's been labeled a predator and there's not the evidence.
That is always going to be meta-commentary. That's always going
to be meta-drama around it. >> Oh, sure. Yeah, I think
I think dangerous predator, I agree there. I Again, we could
quibble over predator, but to me we're like so close to the same
page. That's why we can't resolve it there. Like we're so close
to agreeing that something here is like off and it might rise
to something like that or or it's like a a disagreement on what
that word means. To me, when that happens, you disambiguate.
You just get rid of the word and you start talking about other
things around it. Right? But other people want to focus on that
word because it lets them stop thinking about things. They hear
it and their brain shut off. They go, "Oh, he's predator." Wait,
you didn't prove that he like raped women.
And so I think that's a problem with
That's That's like a problem with everybody not being able to
do that. It's like broadly a problem with
Unironically, it's like a major problem people have, right? But
I'm willing to say, "Okay, let's get rid of that and now discuss
this again." If you But if you But I think everybody would wants
to go, "No, no, no, no, no, you can't get rid of that. That's
really important." And I'm like, "It's not really. It's actually
not really. That's like the whole point of content creators who
do this stuff, who analyze this, is they go, "Oh, this was too
far, but now I'm going to actually analyze what happened here
and talk about it."
>> Uh okay, sure. >> And I think when you do the
when you when you do the thing that the cattle do, and you say,
"Oh, that word is really bad, and that's all I can focus on now."
I'm not even accusing you of this, cuz I know you're doing it
more cuz I disagreed with like some take you had on Twitter.
Where it's like the difference in our positions. I'm not even
accusing you of doing this. But I think a lot of people on Twitter
do this, where they they will never move past that. They will
never see Sykuno is forever like an awesome guy. Actually, W
Sykuno, he's got sick rizz, because they said the word predator,
and now they're lying about everything. That is like broadly
the reaction I'm seeing, and what I don't like. Not a fan.
>> Uh okay, you can be you can be not a fan. Uh I think
broadly my take on it is that Syku- Sykuno is that Syke
Hold on. Sykuno has done something bad here. The uh girlfriend
is the primary victim, and I don't really care that much about
the person that he's been like with for 2 months. That's kind
of it. I think there's some stuff in the document that is like
relatively laughable, unless you really kind of like crane your
neck to like give it maximum credulity.
And I feel as though Okay, here's my here's my read on this,
okay? I think
whether or not these guys have actually seen the evidence, I
think that this person, okay, because of possibly personal reasons
to do with her relationship with Sykuno, okay, has got a lot
of animosity towards him. I Mujin as well is very confident that
these rumors are going to be true. Hence why they're asking other
people to come out with all this stuff, okay? But I think they
are confident.
They are confident that there's something deeper here that they've
not exposed in their document.
>> But I think that the the the fact that there's personal
animosity on her part and Mujin being confident there's more
stuff there if he digs a little deeper is making them massively
overplay their hand with the way they describe it. Cuz I think
that somebody else is going to be able to like come in and give
the evidence to vindicate them. >> Um I don't think they
think somebody else is going to give the evidence. I think they
basically are trusting that there's like a large enough pattern
of women. It's like a Cosby thing, right? Not that people have
proof of this, but that people there's like uh so many women
who have had a similar experience and will say they had a similar
similar experience that they can like confidently say this is
happening. >> They can confidently say that this is happening.
Yeah, but okay. I'm talking when I'm thinking about that, I'm
thinking about the the the label dangerous predator.
>> So what do you think? >> What do you think they're
getting at that he does all the time? What do you think this
the system is set up to do? >> Exploit
uh smaller female content creators. I think that's the allegation
that they're making.
They're constantly talking about victims that he's exploiting.
So no no no, sorry. What's the dangerous predation that is happening?
What do you think they're saying is the dangerous predation that's
happening? >> I think that it's in his engagement with
smaller content creators. >> What Wait, what is But there
aren't any like Hold on. You have to No, no, no. You have to
say as you're receiving it. So when they when they're saying
dangerous predation, you read this. What is the dangerous predation
they think is happening? Or are you saying that they don't think
dangerous predation means what you think? >> people into
>> That's what I The way that I'm reading if you're asking
me what I'm reading, not what I think pressuring them. >> Given
what's in the document.
>> There's no evidence of that.
>> That's the This is a rumor. >> Okay. That he pressures
women into >> And I think that >> What? What's in
>> think that Mutin is thinking that more evidence could
come out about this down the line. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah, okay. That's
I guess it's uh >> Do you disagree with that? >> Do
I disagree with that?
>> Cuz in this document, there's discussion about more
people coming forward. In Mutin's video, there's discussion about
getting people to reach out and speak out. And then Mutin writes
a tweet and publishes that talking about more people speaking
out.
Um I do think more people will speak out, so to speak. >> where
people are discussing this video. >> Well, I actually think
literally somebody just came out like 2 seconds ago, right at
the start of the stream. Where did I put the tweet? I think I
liked it. Hold on. Did you see this one
>> You sent me this tweet. >> hours ago, Sukko the
Angel. You see this one? I don't even know what this is. It's
very very non-specific. Non-specific. Hold on. Uh "Sykuno disrespected
my physical boundaries and clearly has a disregard for consent
in general. He's one of the most powerful men in streaming and
he's used that power to take advantage of women who thought they
could trust him. I was still a teenager when he targeted me."
What do you think when when Nicholas Deorio reads this tweet,
what do you think he's going to get upset about here? Cuz I know
exactly what he's going to be
>> probably a When they're probably an
>> Which is so Like I don't This reading This is like indicative
of the sickness that's in this space that annoys me so much.
Like this person clearly hates Sykuno. So, what they're doing
when they say teenager is not trying to say
They're saying I was young and vulnerable. If I meant I would
say minor. I would say They're saying the worst thing they can
say here, right?
And there's just no way to read this and say actually they're
trying to say
Cuz they're obviously in a state of mind where they would say
the worst thing they can about the person. >> I think they're
trying to I think they're trying to signal towards being young
and inexperienced.
That blurs the line between the two.
>> but not >> in any way. What? Why do you not think
>> Because if they because if they had any allegation,
if they could say he was a they would say that. But this is the
difference between The whole point of being a content creator
should be that you are more intelligent than the total cattle
that watch you. So, when you read this, you go, "Hey cattle.
Hey Hey sheep in the audience. You might read that and
But this person is clearly in the state of mind where they will
say the worst thing they can about this person. So, this doesn't
mean It clearly means 18 or 19 because if they could say 17 or
they would say those words. >> Yeah, I agree that's how
to read it. And yet somebody choosing to use the word teenager
rather than disambiguating and like clarifying that they're an
adult. Um yeah, I think that's like important, though. I think
it's totally fine for somebody to get annoyed at somebody else
using the word teenager when they actually should >> This
person clearly feels like like hurt or put out or like they're
emotional. Why would you Why would you not take their emotional
state in the mind and say this is what you should hear here?
>> Because you think that most people are cattle and that
most people run and say like, "Oh my god, wait. Is this guy
I think even Otherwise Otherwise if that weren't the case, there's
no reason
Uh even if that were the case or sorry, even if that's uh
If that weren't the case, if the cattle didn't do that, then
there would be no reason to freak out over teenager at >> If
the cattle didn't do that, I would >> Sure. So, your job
should be to point out what this actually means.
>> There's an ambiguity there. >> But this person
is in an an emotional state that you should read into reading
the tweet. >> In terms of the way that you interpret it
to find out what's true, yeah, you don't think you can ever critique
the way that somebody presents something.
>> Only if it's like from a dispassionate place. That's
Sorry, you can critique it. You can critique it. But the critique
is this person's emotional, right? This person's emotional. They've
They're reading about these Icy Snow allegations and they're
emotional and this is what they said.
This is what they mean. You should discount this because they're
emotional. You should take this away because they're emotional.
In fact, this sounds very non-specific. It sounds like like basically
this could be almost nothing.
And they're emotional.
I don't hold that against a person. Like I'm not I don't think
this is a person who's a content creator like me. I don't expect
them to have like their head on straight when they are thinking
that this person's like a dangerous predator that they didn't
actually accuse of something and now they've actually targeted
women.
>> Uh sure. Do you know you generally you don't find it
annoying when people use the word teenager and they don't specify
or disambiguate that from adults and the the thing that happens
in the space cuz your assumption >> I don't >> is
that the castle don't take it that way but the castle do actually
take it that way.
>> I I literally don't cuz I I can understand it. This
person is trying to hint that they were young and naive, right?
But they know they're not they're not even remotely hinting.
>> Instead of saying the age, they're saying teenager to
lean into it to lean into a certain implication that a certain
ambiguity.
>> So instead of using >> that. That's completely
understandable based on their emotional state as you say. I 100%
understand why they've done >> Sure. I don't get annoyed
at them when that happens.
>> I don't get annoyed at them when that happens cuz it's
like it they're basically saying something to me that is I like
I read this and I read 18 or 19 and so I don't get annoyed at
all. If I saw like a consistent pattern from somebody of doing
that over time of consistently doing this with regards to the
same person, then I would start calling it >> to be a consistent
pattern?
>> Because then it's like actually their state of mind.
They're actually consistently trying to do something. Here it's
like the emotional person. >> state of mind doing it over
time?
>> Uh it could be. You just don't have any way to tell
and I think it's reasonable to suspect that their state of mind's
[__] up.
Wait, why?
The state of mind's [__] up. Like they going through
a panic attack as they're typing this out?
They're like becoming temperature regulated in some way.
>> Yeah, that they're just regulated in some way. >> Where's
your read of that?
>> Uh cuz it's to tweet something this non-specific out?
Cuz you're going to put yourself in the center of all of this
and you don't even have a story like written down or figured
out. Obviously a rash decision. >> Possibly. Um identified
by that read. I'm not convinced by that.
>> Okay. I It seems like really obvious to >> You
want to say that's You want to say I'll agree with you. Yeah.
>> It's It is. >> What teenager instead of like specifying
the name? >> This whole thing This whole thing This whole
tweet is like stupid. >> Wait, why do you think that? I
don't agree with that. >> Because it's it's not specific.
The whole thing is non-specific.
Disrespect my physical boundaries and clearly has a disregard
for consent in
Like this is something that every single person, once this actually
comes out what happened with this person, this is something that
they're everybody's going to go, "Are you serious?" >> Yeah,
because it was ambiguous enough to have contributed to a story
and let other people speculate intentionally.
>> Yeah, it's a stupid tweet to make. When I read this,
I'm like, I don't take this seriously. This whole thing is just
somebody who's like
and I'm not going to like try to hold this against them for the
rest of their life. It's It should be just thrown >> Hold
it against them for the rest of their life. >> Yeah, cuz
I'm watching I watch at the beginning of this, okay? I'm watching
this at the beginning. >> into a drama and is being as
non-specific as possible to allow others to speculate. You know
that's why they're doing that, right?
>> No, I don't think so. I think they genuinely feel like
they should get this off their chest.
That is That is my read cuz that is almost always the thing.
>> Because they because it is something that is like a
gray area and they don't want to say the gray area in the same
way they don't want to say teenager. >> Why would they
Wait, wait, wait. Why would they not want to say the exact age,
like 18, 19? Why would they want to opt in and like go for the
gray area?
Cuz they could just say 18 19. >> Cuz I just because
I literally just said that they want to say the worst thing they
can about this person.
>> Yes, exactly. Right, so we agree. >> They're saying
things without other spec >> I said from the very beginning.
>> You disagree with me. >> premise of my entire
reading of this. >> to allow other Wait, no, no. I said
that they're saying something to allow other people to speculate
and you said no. You disagreed with that a second ago.
>> That I think they're say Sorry, they're saying this
to get it off their chest and they're angry. I don't think it's
It's literally they're not thinking about how they're Uh how
do I put this?
They're not thinking. They're disregulated. They're not thinking.
If you were logically thinking about this, this is totally to
tweet out, right? They're angry about something. They're upset.
They're tweeting this out and now I'm like, oh, well, this is
here and I'm watching, you know, the girlfriend who said he was
a cheater like 8 years ago also got harassed by his fans, right?
I'm seeing like a major sickness in like this space that's very
frustrating to me. Okay. I >> Um So you're saying that
I I would agree with you that it might not be fully thought out
and if they were to think about it longer or if somebody went
to them, "Hey, you probably want to be specific with this stuff."
Like, "Ah, yeah, okay, I can see that would be the better thing
to do in myself interest." But you agree in that angry. They
want to do damage to Sykkuno and so they're leaning into this
gray area to be able to do damage to him, right? It's not well
thought out. But it's still something bad that >> It's
one of a couple It's one of a couple things. >> It's just
what happens to people do this, right? >> Cuz now I'm thinking
of like a different scenario, but it's In general, when I read
it, I obviously don't read this as 16, 17, 15, 16, 17.
Right? I actually read this as basically >> agreed that
the cattle could or the cattle do
or the intent here is for people to run with it, right? >> I
don't know if that's the intent. Again, I don't know if that's
the >> that they're angry. They're angry. They want to
do damage to this person. They're angry. >> do frame it
as is leaning into this thing that's going on, but I don't know
if it's like, oh, I want people to say like, oh, he's a now.
You know what I mean?
>> What do they want What's the What's the What's the secondary
thought then? After they think >> I'm not sure. I just
I I feel like when people do this
>> Yeah, when
When people Again, I think if it was about Sykkuno
she would be like lying.
It's like a mix in between.
Um it's it's like, at least in my experience, when women are
doing this, it's like or anybody's doing this, not just women
for other things, too. It's like to talk to to like the other
people that they think are victims, right? Hey, this did happen.
>> He called >> It's to talk to other victims. >> Yeah,
she's like leaning into it, trying to give them like um
like coverage or something.
In any case, I Like that's what I read here, right?
She's angry at him.
But like it's not about trying to paint him as a necessarily.
It's about trying to make sure that more victims don't come about
is like the way these people lean into this stuff. Or what they
tell themselves, at least. >> Yeah, that's a That's a read.
Yeah, I don't I don't see I just I Maybe you got different experiences.
I don't see that. I think that it's just like far more far more
simple that they don't like the guy and so, yeah, they lean and
say the worst thing possible. >> In any case, it's like
it To me, when I read this tweet
the general point is
like leaving aside that, which is it is kind of mind reading,
I guess, but leaving aside that, I don't take this seriously
without anything like else being attached here. Like this is
essentially nothing.
Basically, look at this and I go like it's like nothing. >> Yeah,
I think I agree. Yeah. If it's not like DMs or other like corroborating
evidence, yeah, sure. I forgot why we brought this up.
>> Oh, I was just saying that more women are coming out
that more women are coming forward. I didn't get a chance to
read this before I started. Well, I think I read disrespect my
physical boundaries and then I moved on to something else.
From an angel, this makes me so angry. I'm so strong. Sorry,
I'm so sorry you had to deal with this sort of thing in silence.
You're a very strong person. Is a response to that tweet. Very
cool. Did I send it to you or is it am I just showing it on my
Send it to you, good. >> I'll reply underneath.
No way that he uses the word angel. >> Oh, they reply Yeah,
they reply underneath. Yeah, it's very funny. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Anyway, um >> Um regarding what we I don't
know what else we disagree with. >> I'm also laying out
like some thoughts I've been having about this that I basically
haven't had a chance to like verbalize until basically today.
This is a little disconnected. I'd have to collect a little bit,
but I do think there's like something here. The reaction to this
is like
actually super
incorrect to me. Like I think the analysis from a lot of people
is incorrect and what I see in terms of what people focus on
is incorrect. I'm just unsure if it's like
I think it's all the gender thing. I think it's like
essentially the thing that led to Teccy being able to like have
a stream and be a content creator post his allegations.
I think it's all downstream of that. >> Uh I I would say
that as like a commentator from like Mouton's perspective describing
this as or retweeting or if he has had some kind of hand in it
which we both seem to agree um to what extent up to question,
okay. Maybe I'll send Mouton a uh a reply on Twitter and ask
him. Um I think that including the term predatory is pretty reckless
in the exact same way that like saying teenager rather than specifying
the age. >> I think it just comes down >> Mouton
is doing the exact same kind of uh and I don't like that. I don't
like that. I think that he I do okay, this is 100% 100% speculation.
I wonder if there might be another reason that he wants to go
at Sakura.
maybe. I thought this was way more I thought I think this is
way more likely for the girl who wrote the document, the Heba
Mal girl. That that I think what would be happening here if that
were the case is the Heba Mal girl has another reason to go after
him. I e I do think there's a decent chance it comes out that
he broke contact with contact with
That he actually like blocked her.
>> No no no no no no no. I I I I don't think people are
reading that right. To be honest with you. We could we could
listen to that or maybe I'll listen to it after, but um in the
call I don't think he's saying that. I think he's So I guess
you're done with me then. I think that's what he's saying. He's
like this is done then. I don't think he was actually saying
I'm cutting off contact with you. I think he was asking a question.
>> Oh, really? Okay. >> Like like the way he says
it it is it is a statement. Sorry, it is a statement, but the
way he is leaning into it, the whole vibe he's giving the whole
time, this like small bean vibe that he's given the entire conversation,
that's like >> So I guess you're just done with me then.
I guess this is done. I think that's what it was.
That like beating himself up, and I think she responded to it
in the exact way that's a gig of manipulation by the way, and
but I think she responded to it in the exact way he expected.
I'm not I'm not done with you necessarily, which is really funny.
That's how I that's how I heard it. That's how I read it. And
I think a bunch of people are reading it the opposite way, the
way you are. So maybe not. Maybe I give it a second listen or
something. >> I feel like after what you've said I I feel
like we're hearing like yeah, two different calls. So I might
need to go back and relisten to it. Did you watch the end of
the Mujin video after the ad
>> Oh, maybe not. >> Yeah, I feel like I like >> Sakura
just followed you? That one?
>> Yeah, that's the one that's the one. That's the one.
>> Yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
>> So, I'd say that the way that Muji has handled it, um,
if you were let's I'll just ask you. If you were running this
story
and you were given advice, the girl has come to you and say,
"Hey, listen, okay? I'm not sure whether should call him a predator.
I'm not sure whether I could I should call him a dangerous predator.
Maybe we know stuff in the background, but with the information
that we're
okay? Do you think that the girl would ask the question you're
asking on the testimony that we're running with?
>> You're adding all these qualifiers. The girl the girl
would just say is this or something if she was if she was checking
with him, but I don't know if she was.
>> No, no, I'm asking you. Would you say that that's a
reasonable label to be able to attach like a guy in the happy
drama community? >> Again, I
I think you shouldn't, but I think I'm going to keep arguing
that there's just no reason to focus in on it. It's really not
that significant to me. And also, it would depend cuz I would
be totally comfortable with it if I'd seen like, you know, if
Bao had shared DMs with like four content creators I'd confirmed
had had like meetings with Sykkuno who all had the same the same
pattern of behavior and all said that they had like weird interactions
with him at cons, I'd be okay with that.
Right? But I would need I would need like proof positive. Yeah,
she shared those DMs and you because they weren't ready to come
forward, you couldn't share them and they said don't even don't
even share like literally any part of it because we don't want
to be identified, right? Like you can't even don't talk about
it beyond just saying that I told you it, don't talk about it,
right? But if I saw that stuff, I would need to see it. Like
you can't can't just go off their word as the content creator
is putting this out. And if it comes out that none of that stuff
existed or was vastly overblown, then yeah, I think he's nuked
himself.
I think I largely agree. To your point about like what helps
or doesn't help Tectone and I'm not making this up as like a
an old >> I'm not saying none of this helps None of this
helps Tectone at all. Sorry, I said it's like these are like
lesser Tectones. Like it's all people who want to try to like
redirect the anger and a lot of people do it like vicariously
for the content creator. Like literally like I think there are
a bunch of like total losers with no hope in life who live vicariously
through content creators. They're all on Twitter and they all
have the same thing where like any man is accused of essentially
anything and they will go on the other side of it and I'm just
like I'm so done with these people.
Um but I thought you said earlier that like the um the reaction
to like go and like question or do meta commentary helps people
like Tectone. Is that not what you said? >> Oh, no. I mean
like literally if the only thing you're focused on is the meta
commentary and you barely like if you're if all of your anger
is at the meta com is on the meta commentary level and like none
of it is essentially for the actual
then I'm like oh, that's kind seems kind of goofy. >> Okay,
fair enough. I think that like um go and waste your thoughts
uh using the word predator. I think that is almost always going
to be like a bad move cuz Tectone can just point it out and say
like oh, you know Mujin? Yeah, the guy who was coming out supporting
the victim that a lot of people apparently changed their [__]
mind because of? Yeah, that's what that guy means when he says
predator by the way. No evidence for this stuff. There's no evidence.
This guy just calls people predators like crazy. >> Is
this a stan dude? I feel like is this a standard we've had before
the past like 2 years?
If I go back and
Yeah, I'm trying to think. >> I don't know. Is it is it
a post Me Too is it a post Me Too standard? >> I'm not
sure. I'm trying to think of like the the
I can say that I'm trying to think back to like the Turkey Tom
thumbnail memes. You know what I'm talking about? Like creep
pedo whatever.
I can't remember what it is. Weirdo creep pedo pedo creep whatever
the [__] he does in his thumbnails. Yeah, yeah. I'm
trying to think if like using stuff like that is that is that
not I feel like there was a meme where he would over blow like
with his thumbnail and title like what was actually proven out
in his
Liar, creep, pedo. Yeah, yeah, sure, sure, sure.
Did people go as hard at him as they're going to go at Muffin?
>> I think I think thumbnails got like a free pass. Thumbnails
and thumbnails and titles has got a free pass. So, for example,
when Chud calls Lerix
and says that he's got a free
>> Wait, are you not quite literally the same thing?
How is how is the tweet not like essentially the the title?
I feel like And again, it's technically in the doc at the very
end.
>> Okay, I'm not I'm not talking about the standard we're
doing like how do people see this? Again, we're coming back to
how people perceive that stuff.
All right. >> I don't think people treat thumbnails and
titles particularly seriously, especially not from somebody like
Turkey
>> Do you think Turkey Tom's a less reliable narrator than
Muffin? >> No, I think that Muffin's like stuff up before.
I think he rides like popular opinion on stuff all the time.
>> Does he?
I think the only other video I've watched from him is the Kaede
video, the Kaede Tens video that it was okay.
>> You need to go back and watch the Marvel Rivals video.
I was tearing my hair out.
Did you cover the Marvel Rivals drama?
Um I'm trying to think of what I thought about it. >> I
think I'm going to I'm going to change your perspective on this
entire drama right now, okay? Muffin made a video about the Marvel
Rivals drama and followed, supported,
backed up the
my Marvel Rivals guy, can't remember this guy's name, the entire
way and called those Sorry, sorry. Called those women
the entire way through. They're evil, they're bullying, they're
ganging up on
>> think this guy has good good good good coverage at all.
No.
>> Isn't that the majority opinion on that
>> Uh yeah, which is why I said it in the
>> Yeah, but like sorry, I what I say isn't that like basically
what most people
Like is it sorry, I I keep saying the same thing. Is it that
like what content creators like most analysts of that situation
think? Like even like everybody's on the same page there. I mean
like >> Um when people are talking like in specific in
general, uh yes, but it's a lot more when somebody does like
a 2-hour video going through all the nitty-gritty and like saying
this, this is where they were bullying and ganging up on the
guy. I think that that has soured my view on Mujin. That has
soured my view on Mujin.
>> I think the only thing I the only way I had to defend
those people is that I was just basically like yeah, this guy's
like really sweaty and I understand that it's like totally off-putting
to normal people. That was like the only way I had to defend
those people. But then they just kept getting worse in like the
stuff that came out that they were basically like all colluding
behind the scenes to with this guy the whole time. I think they
they look a lot worse like as that drama unfolds now.
Like I I I was willing to give them that they're like hey, this
guy's like really sweaty, he's kind of annoying, but like they
basically immediately start going back at him pretty hard and
I didn't think he was I I I expected to be totally against him
given the first like 20 minutes of me covering that and then
by the end I was like oh, actually the wasn't the socially one
this time. Was what I remember about it. >> We don't need
to go back through the Marvel Marvel Rivals drama, but uh no,
I think I I think I disagree. So for example, like a lot of the
claims made are like or the way that it's framed a lot of the
time is that people will speak neutrally or in support of the
game organizer guy cuz he can quote-unquote take accountability.
Now it seems like he's the one actually who decided to fire the
guy from the event, but despite that all the women still get
all the heat for it despite them not actually being the ones
to decide to kick him from the event.
I think apparently one of their boyfriends was sending him clips
and complaints and then that got her
>> But still the organizing guy is like a neutral party
in the drama and the girls are the villains. >> Yeah, but
they I mean the organizer is just trying to like keep the peace
and not have people drop out, right? Like I I think they the
girls also I believe sourced most of the document for him. Did
they not? Did they not help him build that document? >> Uh
I believe he was just sending clips in DMs.
>> I thought I thought there was a whole >> how the
guy initially got fired. Um there was a couple documents, but
those were the girls like explaining their side of the drama
and one of their boyfriends, the same boyfriend, did help with
making that making that breakdown. But that was after the fact.
That never got sent to organizers.
>> Oh, wait. Didn't people So somebody in chat is saying
that everybody was on the organizer guy. He just said, "I'm sorry.
I really this up right away." And the girls basically did the
thing where they fought the
They They fought fate. Doesn't work.
>> Yeah, like they're all extremely dislikable, okay? Don't
get me wrong with the way they handled the drama was like bad,
but yeah. In terms of the person to actually be annoyed out in
the drama, it's the organizer guy.
He was the one who actually got kicked from the event. >> Yeah,
but I also think >> want to go through and say the girls
are like, "Yeah, these girls are like really dislikable people,
lolcow material." Yeah, but people people don't do that. People
blame them for the entire course of the drama. >> Maybe.
Yeah, sure.
Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um but no, I think that going back to I
guess what we were talking about like before, I think that it
might be like a post me too thing that people are a little bit
tighter on language and exactly what you're alleging. And sometimes
it can be used in bad faith as word games and people can use
it to their advantage, but I think broadly it's like in terms
of moderating public discourse, which is not something that we
see very often online. It's like a net net It's like a net positive,
sorry. >> I think both sides are using it in this case.
I think they're using it and the side supporting Cy Kono is using
it and I'm just like I want to ignore it. I think that's totally
fine.
>> Well, can't you can't you not like Cy Kono and then
still disagree with the language used? >> Yeah. I did I
I think >> Hey everyone involved >> I I understand
but I probably what I'm saying here is I think as long as this
guy is like, you know, he's got a massive channel where he makes
a ton of money. Like he's got tons of huge videos in this channel,
right? Like he is making an insane amount of money that he would
be willing to put his like career on this. I'm fine with like
I essentially take the bell allegations as like yes, she does
have multiple women who are telling a fairly consistent story,
building a consistent pattern of like hey, he's, you know, buying
drinks repeatedly for smaller content creators, consistently
pushing towards like a interaction in a way that they felt uncomfortable
with, right? I if they don't have that I don't know why he would
do this other than I guess maybe he's like just a massive simp.
I I can't see it personally. So I'm I'm just I'm counting that
part to me.
>> What's that?
>> I don't think that it has to be that he's a massive
simp this argument. I didn't mean to interrupt you.
>> Okay. But yeah, like I I just like to me I'm willing
to take that on like a little bit of faith
because of some of the other stuff that's come out, I guess.
I I read it maybe Well, no, cuz you only read it today, right?
>> Uh yeah, I didn't I didn't pre-read any of this stuff.
>> Okay. Well, no, I just mean like so I had the advantage
of like the I think there's like 7 or 8 hours of conversation
that had happened on Twitter before I ended up
Yeah, before I ended up doing anything. There's probably like
7 or 8 hours of conversation on Twitter. So I I probably have
the benefit of like oh, I get to see more women come out. But
then I think you are covering it today, so you probably would
have seen a lot of women come out, too. And like add little bits.
Not like nobody came out who was like this guy me, obviously.
It was just like, hey, I yeah. >> I saw other girls saying
that like oh, we'd like he's with me. Yes.
But in terms of somebody came in out coming out and making like
additional allegations, there was more confirmation of the cheating,
but I don't think we needed extra confirmation of that, right?
That was like nailed on. This guy's like a cheater. >> Yeah,
there was one thing where he basically got like a little
like I I would describe it as the person didn't like him. He
was like in Seattle for something TFT tournament or
That was one where it was like, okay, it seems to be the same
sort of pattern of he talks to the smaller content creator. Although
again with that one, I got the I got the general idea that he
just that she wanted to [__] him. So, I don't Again,
it's really weird, but apparently by the time they get back to
her place, she says no and he like makes one more move and then
she pushes him away and he goes, okay, bye.
Which like I got you you tried it.
You tried it. No, I don't I don't think that's like really it's
indicative of like he's expecting this to just work and and he's
probably done this quite a few times, but it's not indicative
of like he's overtly like disregarding boundaries or anything,
which I think is what they'd imply there.
What do you think his amorous, all right, since we're doing them.
What's your opinion on why this guy's cheating?
You seem to know a little bit more about this guy than you know
than me, so
>> I don't I don't No, no, no, I don't I genuinely hate
him from having watched like 90 seconds of his content. I genuinely
have burning passionate hatred for him after watching 90 seconds.
I've not seen more than that before I covered
I've heard him speak in that stupid anime voice for like 90 seconds
and I'm like, yeah, this guy guy yeah, he
belongs in prison to get a sunset, belongs under the prison more
like,
Get him out of here. Anyway,
I assume, and I think this is backed up, that he was like not
super attractive early in his life, even into his 20s. While
he wasn't a virgin, he was not super attractive or somebody women
sought. Right? He had like a fairly a not to talk or homely like
Asian girlfriend, and they were together, and he cheated on her.
He just seems like somebody who's always wanted validation. That's
like the thing that gets streamers big, right? Is you're just
constantly seeking validation, way to like make your audience
like you more. And that finally he's getting the attention from
women he wanted. He's getting like what he what he's always wanted
in his life, which is just more validation and attention. He's
attractive, he's cool, and that's why he's cheating.
Once that feeling all the time, which is why I think he's probably
a little bit fine, too, with like if it just is like video games
and these girls being obsessed with them. I think I think this
is just like on top of it. I don't even know like he's going
to an event. He could have easily been like trying to find more
elaborate ways to like more, right? And he doesn't. I think he
just wanted the girls like obsessed with him,
>> Do you buy him saying that his relationship with his
girlfriend isn't
yeah. Yeah, I I buy it.
I I don't buy Sorry, I don't buy it as in like it excuses anything.
I don't buy it in terms of I buy it in terms of I I'm willing
to bet that he is wanted to break up for a while, and he's the
kind of guy who like can't get the stones, you know, he can't
summon the the courage to do it. And so he's just going to consistently
let things deteriorate over time until she eventually ends it.
I would assume. >> Yeah. I mean, that was um that was my
read. Either he's like one of the guys who doesn't want to be
single and lonely >> How did you get that read? How did
you get that read? >> I get that read?
>> Um like from the from the call, I guess. >> Oh,
no, I mean like how did you get
I'm just I've I've done that before in a relationship. And I
I just know exactly what I That's how I got it is like I I can
see I've been that guy who like lets the thing deteriorate until
the other person breaks up with you. And I'm like, "Yeah, I see
it. That's a piece of [__] thing to do. You shouldn't
do that to other people, but I've done it before, so that's how
I know." I was asking that. Like, how did you identify that?
>> Oh, from like personal experience.
Okay. >> Um That's what I meant. Was I was like, "I've
been that guy, so I just I can see exactly what you're doing
here. I see >> Well, no, no, no, no, no, no. I listen,
I'm not confessing to more than I'm confessing. All right? Oh
well, there's nothing to confess to me. Okay. >> I've never
I've never like cheated. I just know like things are bad and
it's like I'm just going to avoid the situation for as long as
possible and then eventually they'll leave.
I That's a horrible thing to do to another person.
>> Especially when you're living together. >> Yeah,
that is a horrible thing when you're I I That wasn't the case
for me,
it's rough. >> Cuz I'm thinking like how much how much
like how much of a pain barrier is there going to be to like
end in that
>> And well, the other thing is is if they've been together
for 4 years, I don't know what California's like. It seemed like
Oh, no, California I think is good on this, but some divorce
laws you can end up common law and he's probably earned a significant
amount of money while living with this girl.
And so there could be considerations there, too, where like if
he if he divorces her, he might open himself like maybe there's
some legal element there. I haven't even looked into that. >> I
didn't even think about that. >> But there's no common
law in California. That's why XQC tried to say that like him
and Adept lived in California, so there's no grounds to bring
a divorce suit in Texas.
Even though they lived in Texas for a short period of time, cuz
Texas does do common law.
Yeah, I was I was just thinking more so like you put a whole
like reorganize your life. Uh that's like a big thing. Eventually
suddenly you want to break up with somebody you live with.
Yeah, that's rough. That's rough. That's uh that's something
you're going to mull over for months, but uh Yeah, awful. Awful.
>> A couple times he was like he
I I feel like did this happen or am I making this up? Did he
not say like I kind of wanted I hope things would get better,
but now I know they're not going to get better and that's published.
It's going to be really awkward if they do stay together. Um
it's going to be tough, man. >> Oh man. Do we We don't
know who this girl is, do we?
>> Uh we do. I mean I do. She's a VTuber artist, a really
popular VTuber artist who probably actually makes a significant
amount of money. She's maybe not hurting at all. Yeah, she's
one of like the old >> that you >> We We need to
ask people or like No, I mean it's it's all but confirmed that
it's Weenie Desu.
>> Twitter. Yeah. Um people knew this a long time ago and
while I don't think it's come out somehow it's come out and I
can't remember, but basically this was like a theory people had
before
and it has come out through somewhere in
at some point.
Uh she had like some freak out when Sykkuno went to a strip club
and talked about how all men are pigs and strip clubs are like
evil and like this. >> Okay, right right right. That makes
a little bit more sense then. >> That was why people suspected
it and
>> That was like I don't know, years ago. They went for
like a bachelor party, like one of those OTV people's bachelor
party.
>> Yeah, so
>> It It is this VTuber artist. I don't know what she looks
like.
>> Has he ever been public with any of his
>> Well, this is No, the other Well, I mean I think this
girlfriend's been his girlfriend essentially since
What, 20 2021? So they've been together since like basically
his a lot of his streaming career.
I He would have met her through Lily. I think she's done a lot
of work for >> Mm okay. Okay. She was also his VTuber modeler
for his VTuber, apparently. >> Yeah. Yeah, she was.
She's She's slaving away in the sweatshop and he's going to all
these VTuber conferences with random
>> Okay. Was there any other Was there any any other part
of that that we that we disagreed on?
What do you think? What do you think about the implication about
the fact that he's uh he was not following these people and then
as soon as the video is released he is following them. >> Oh,
I thought that was really stupid cuz he literally said from the
beginning that he was like talking to them.
Like he said in the comment on the video that's made at the same
time and it's like obvious by releasing the video he was talking
to them beforehand anyway.
So like
Like I I I don't know what you would expect. Maybe maybe you
expect like a disclaimer at the start of the video or the end
of the video that says I talked to these people beforehand.
But I think it's like I
I think most people by and large don't give a [__]
anyway like 99% of people and for the 1% who do like they would
just be aware of the comment.
Like for the number of people who are watching this thinking
about like his level of involvement that's like 1% maybe 0.1%
of the audience.
And for those people who care about that it's disclosed in the
comment.
>> I do I would agree that maybe if he put maybe if he
put a disclaimer at the beginning of the video then people could
care or it might like lessen their ability to take it seriously
and so maybe there's I don't know if you'd say it's required
for him to do that because it does like allow people to calibrate
their seriousness
like better like how seriously they take
>> Like basically the same argument around like uh PV and
taking money there, >> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> that it's going to change somebody's like point of view
given the fact that you give like a small full disclosure rather
than leading people to like have it in front of >> if they
put a comment on the video that said hey I did interact with
these people I did talk to these people beforehand then I like
I literally is sponsored by PV.
>> Like that would be enough of a disclosure if they put
it in the comments on the video or if they put it in the description
of the video, that would be enough of a disclosure to me for
PV. >> I mean the the PV example breaks down cuz some people
work on PV panels without being paid by PV, right?
>> Yeah, but I'm saying this guy literally disclosed on
the video in question where he has like this this like potential
conflict, he disclosed that that conflict existed in a comment.
So like for me if if they're doing a PV video where they were
getting paid by PV or if it was a sponsored hit and they disclosed
it, I just had would have no criticism for them. >> Okay,
I feel like you're taking you're taking what I'm saying and and
running with it in a slightly different
It's slightly too literal, yeah. So what I'm saying is that uh
if you if there's a concern there that I don't want to in- I
don't want to include the fact that commentary and flight handle
this hypothetical
the hypothetical concern.
>> Yeah, the hypothetical concern exists if you don't make
it clear to the audience and the audience might not look at the
comment. Like maybe if people just don't care, they're not going
to look at the comment. So broadly the audience um isn't even
going to realize that there could be a concern there to be
>> Um and I I I don't think that he discloses anything
in that comment that he doesn't already disclose in the
Cuz he says that he received it from
>> Oh, did he say he received it from them ahead of time?
>> Um I mean yeah, he was like he says that at the beginning,
>> Okay, I'm sorry. I think that's disclosing and I think
he disclosed it in the video. He did even more than I
>> I do actually I do actually think that's >> he's
got some kind of like editorial
editorial like collaboration here.
>> I'm saying no, I don't I don't see evidence of that.
I'm saying that when he says I got this from them like they trusted
me, I get the implication they collaborated. That's like to me,
that's what I take away there.
>> Okay. Listen, okay. We don't have to do the conversation
for a third time, I just realized. Okay. >> Yeah, but like
maybe this is is difference in terms of like Corus. Let's say
this is the difference between saying I'm working with Corus
or I'm paid by Corus. Like maybe he should do the thing that
is actually a little more like closer to the truth because then
it lets people calibrate like really accordingly. You're not
just like partnered with them once, you're actually getting like
paid but from the by them like each week. Like it's it's not
enough to just say, "Hey, these people trusted me with this."
That doesn't give you the entire story. So if he added, so I
would agree then like I would even give you if he had significant
editorial stuff but beyond reading it and going this looks good
or reading it and saying like maybe this here is like weird and
I don't understand it. If he, you know, suggested anything, if
he reformulated arguments for them, I would say that should be
disclosed.
>> Cuz okay. It might be a personal standard for me, all
right? But if we going back to like um like Cameron Ethier 5
stuff when I was like receiving stuff along from Jelly and she
was like putting out statements or like, you know, explaining
certain bits of uh evidence. If I was telling her like, "Oh,
okay, that statement there, sharpen that stuff up, okay? You
should frame it like this. You shouldn't use that word. You >> Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Right? I think I think
>> I would expect and I said, "I've received this from
Jelly. Jelly's trusted me to be able to read this out to you."
I think that I would be leaving something out there. I put my
thumb in some way on the drama and I'm not disclosing that as
if it's Jelly's authentic stuff, right? I would see that as a
personal guideline. >> It depends on like to what extent.
Like I would expect
Yeah, it really depends on I guess how much you're changing it.
Like if you if you said obviously like most superficial, you
said there's a spelling mistake here. That's not a big deal.
I I know you agree with that. I'm saying most superficial. If
we go along that continuum, if we go along that continuum, it's
like probably making anything that changes substantially away
from like how they felt about it or
how they
interpreted events
at all. Like beyond not even just like to make it sound better
for an audience or to be more accurate, but if you did it at
all, if it substantially changes from what they provided. The
meaning, um, anything like that. I would say maybe you should
disclose that. >> any critiques that I would have when
presenting it to the audience. >> But then let's say, let's
say what if he went in the other direction? What if he
What if he said, "This is a little too far. I don't think you
have evidence to call this guy like a Then what what should he
be disclosing based on that? >> We had a conversation and
after that conversation we this is what she put out. So I'm going
to read this out. >> Okay, I Yeah, I get this >> this
from her.
>> I do I do feel like um cuz he he has >> conversation
before this document was written. Yeah. He has conversations
or he says like, "Oh, well, I asked her this question after the
fact, blah blah
Or I asked this person this question. It's like, "Hmm."
Kind of makes it seem like you're a third party who's just receiving
this
And then it seems like you've been in conversations with these
people throughout the drama that's been happening. You've been
like friends with these people, like their personal confidant.
>> You're thanking them for trusting you as if they shouldn't
have ordinarily trusted you, but it sounds like you're their
friend.
>> Oh, I guess I guess if they did something beyond, so
if I guess if they
friends before, it would depend on yeah, I guess maybe that's
misleading. Like if they were just friends before and therefore
she was already talking to him about this. If she went and sought
him out as a drama person like to tell this story to put this
out with like pair the document with a video.
Then do you not think that would be the same thing? Trusted.
Thank you for trusting me with this. You came to me with this.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Absolutely. >> Okay. So if they
had a long-term relationship before >> came to him with
it. >> Sure. Yeah, I think if a long-term relationship
existed there, that's not disclosed at all. Sure. >> Well,
long long-term a relationship without the course of the drama.
>> As in like like but okay, yeah. So >> So if if
somebody comes to me and says, "Hey Dickers, I've got this thing.
I'm thinking of maybe writing a document about it." And I'm like
talking to them as the drama is evolving and like coming through
and it Yeah, record that call. Yeah, I I'm not saying this has
happened, but if it happened, okay. Record that call. Yeah, okay.
This
And I'm giving them advice throughout on how to handle the situation.
I'm not receiving anything from them. That'd be false to say.
I'm like my my my my fingers are all over that drama, all over
that document. Yeah. And that's like a material difference though.
>> Maybe. I mean, you'd have to again, it would come down
to what it was. What if they were just friends and she was like,
"Hey, I'm going to do something." And he was like, "Okay, well,
I published a guide on Google Docs. I would it would be inappropriate
for me to comment further, so go follow that guide if you want
to write a Google Doc and let me know. I'll I'll cover it."
>> If if that was the case, I would be extremely surprised
if he came out the other end with no notes.
Cuz I can't think of a single disagreement he has. >> hold
on. But that's like literally what I said and that's what I think
is entailed when he says you trusted me with this, to be honest
with you. Like that's that's what I suspect is he had notes at
the end. >> But I I think that that entailment
should be
>> Like in more certain terms, okay.
Yeah, I maybe more specifically it could be disclosed that like,
"Hey, um I helped with this." Yeah. Like then I think for me,
you don't say that. You say, "Here's what I helped with." cuz
I assume you don't want to just say, "I helped with this." in
an open-ended way. >> Yeah, I think that like Like there's
a there's appropriate parameters to put on the stuff. Uh but
I think that some kind of disclosure is probably probably necessary,
yeah. But um
I'm glad that we came to some form of uh of agreement at the
very end there.
Hey, dude. I appreciate you [__] up.
>> Oh, sorry. I I just like
Again, it it really comes down to what his like what happened
with him. Like I I just I still don't think there's like a necessary
thing unless he like had significant editorial decision on the
doc. Like if I found out he had significant editorial decision
on the doc and he said thank you for trusting me with this. I
would think that looks bad. Like in a vacuum it looks bad just
because it's a like a little dishonest, but I
I suspect he had notes and to me that's different than like hey
you've given me your story and it's like hey just so you know
I think people would like attack you over this. Maybe you should
pull this back a little bit. You know what I >> Yeah, how
would it feel about that? Maybe I'd have to think more. Maybe
I'd have to think more.
>> It's like you would have to know how it affected things
to really make a It's funny cuz if you look at our arguments
I think basically your argument over using predator or not is
similar to the argument I'm using over
basically you'd have to know how it unfolded
to make the like true argument that something wrong happened
here.
You're like no inherently and I'm like I don't know. There's
a symmetry that's very funny. Anyway, yeah I think I got to go
cuz apparently um apparently Soy Boy is getting screamed at by
Destiny and Destiny's saying Jstock is controlling you and you
need to figure out your life.
So I Apparently I should check that out. Apparently there's a
sperg session happening about me.
>> Yeah, yeah. We We talked for a lot longer than I than
I asked for or agreed to or sorry that you agreed to but I appreciate
it mate. >> I I don't even like doing commas like this
most of the time without being prepared cuz I I like talking
through my thoughts without being like I'm not really making
arguments. So there there are times here where I'm just like
laying up my thoughts without interrogating them first. So don't
I hope your audience doesn't hold that against me. Cuz I sometimes
just I sometimes just like talk about stuff and how I feel about
it without even I I just like having somebody to bounce my ideas
off of. So I don't know. I I do think that broadly he disclosed
a little bit. It It'll just It'll come down to like how much
did he help to know if he disclosed enough. >> Um yeah,
I think I agree. And same to you. Same to you. Okay? I think
that a lot of the The The call probably could have been two hours
if I was more prepared, so I'll take that on the on the chin
and same to your audience, okay? Have a good one, mate. I'll
chat to you later. >> Thanks for watching the stream. Hope
you enjoyed the sub appeal content. Bye. >> Will do. Bye.